programming throwdown episode 92 basics of ui design for engineers with eric kennedy take it away patrick hey everyone uh we're here with another interview episode. And we've got Eric on the call. And we're got what I think is going to be a pretty exciting topic, something I don't know so much about. And it's a really big field design. And even just UI design, it's always been on my list of, I feel like I've made a few crappy UIs just to get past something. So yeah, definitely. Yeah, I think we've all been there before. So hopefully we'll get some illuminating tips here today. And we have our guest, Eric, Eric Kennedy. Why don't you go ahead and introduce and tell the folks a little bit about yourself? Hey, yeah, thank you. So my name is Eric Kennedy, and I am a freelance UX and UI designer. And I also teach UI and soon to be UX online. But I didn't start there. Like I actually started from a dev background back in the day. I really hadn't
Programming Throwdown 第 92 期：工程师的 UI 设计基础，嘉宾 Eric Kennedy。Patrick，开始吧。嘿，大家好，我们又迎来了一期访谈节目。今天我们请到了 Eric。我们要聊的话题我觉得会非常令人兴奋，也是我不太了解的领域。设计是一个非常大的领域，即使只是 UI 设计，也一直都在我的待办清单上。我觉得我为了应付差事做过一些糟糕的 UI。确实如此，我想我们都经历过。希望今天能从 Eric 那里得到一些启发性的建议。我们有请嘉宾 Eric Kennedy。能请你先介绍一下自己，让大家了解一下你吗？嘿，好的，谢谢。我叫 Eric Kennedy，是一名自由职业 UX 和 UI 设计师。我也在网上教授 UI 设计，很快也会教授 UX 设计。但我并不是从这里开始的。我其实早年是有开发背景的。
programmed at all until I got to college. And then freshman year, very first semester, there was an intro to programming course. And I tried it. And I loved it so much that I ended up switching my major over to software engineering and doing some internships as a dev. But basically, I mean, I kind of drifted my way from there. Like, I really liked developing, but the thing I liked about programming was just doing these little side projects where you kind of, like, thought of an idea. You, like, cranked it out. You know, you worked until 3 a.m. It was just you.
在大学之前我根本没写过代码。大一第一学期，有一门编程入门课。我试了一下，非常喜欢，最后转专业到了软件工程，还做过一些开发实习。但基本上，我是从那里一路摸索过来的。我真的很喜欢开发，但我喜欢编程的原因是做那些小项目，你可以想出一个点子，然后把它做出来。你知道，工作到凌晨 3 点，只有你自己。
You didn't need anyone else's permission. You didn't need anyone else's approval. You just, you could turn whatever you were thinking of into a reality. And I love that. But then doing a couple developer internships, I was like, man, this is, it's a little more like industrial scale than I thought. And it just wasn't quite the same. So I eventually shifted over to PM. And then from there, realized that most of the things I liked about being a PM were things like wireframing new features and talking to users, doing user research or doing usability testing. And at some point, it just sort of dawned on me like, hey, there's a word for doing these things. It's not called being a PM. It's called being a UX designer.
你不需要任何人的许可，也不需要任何人的批准。你只需要把你脑子里的东西变成现实。我喜欢这一点。但做了几次开发实习后，我觉得，天哪，这比我想象的更像工业化规模，感觉不太一样。所以我最终转到了产品经理（PM）。从那里我意识到，我喜欢做 PM 的大部分事情，比如为新功能绘制线框图、与用户交谈、进行用户研究或可用性测试。在某个时刻，我突然意识到，嘿，做这些事情是有专门称呼的。它不叫 PM，它叫 UX 设计师。
So then I jumped into UX design, and I was doing that freelance. And very early on in the course of doing UX design, I'd have clients who would look at these wireframes, right? Because as a UX designer, like one of the final deliverables I'm going to be handing to my clients are these wireframes of their sites or their apps. And it's, you know, they're just these black and white drawings. They're kind of sketchy. You know, maybe they even use Comic Sans as the font. But the point is they just sort of get across, like, here's what's on each page of the app.
所以我跳槽到了 UX 设计，并开始做自由职业。在做 UX 设计的早期，我的客户会看这些线框图，对吧？因为作为 UX 设计师，我交给客户的最终交付物之一就是他们的网站或应用程序的线框图。它们只是黑白的草图，有点简陋。你知道，甚至可能用了 Comic Sans 字体。但重点是它们传达了应用程序每一页上有什么。
And here's how kind of everything flows together. And like the goal is for it to be usable and simple. And it doesn't look very nice, right? So my clients would see this and they'd be like, wow, this is cool. Like, this looks good. But hey, any chance you could, you know, make it look like an app? I'd be like, ah, shoot.
以及一切是如何串联起来的。目标是让它可用且简单。它看起来并不好看，对吧？所以我的客户看到这些会说，哇，这很酷，看起来不错。但是，嘿，有没有可能让它看起来像个真正的应用？我会说，啊，糟糕。
This is so outside of my wheelhouse. My first attempts at trying to make an app look nice, look professional, were just disasters. So I went on this multi-year quest. I mean, it's still continuing. But I went on this multi-year quest where like any good freel's still continuing, but I went on this multi-year quest where like any good freelancer, I said, yeah, yeah, I can do that. I can do that.
这完全超出了我的能力范围。我第一次尝试让应用看起来美观、专业，结果简直是一场灾难。所以我开始了长达数年的探索。我的意思是，这还在继续。但我开始了长达数年的探索，就像任何好的自由职业者一样，我说，没问题，我可以做。我可以做。
And then like frantically scrambled to try and figure out visual design like while doing other UX projects. And it just kind of took off from there. Maybe some of your listeners have stumbled upon an article I wrote. It was back in 2014 at this point called Seven Rules for Creating Gorgeous UI.
然后疯狂地试图在做其他 UX 项目的同时弄清楚视觉设计。事情就这样开始了。也许你们的一些听众偶然发现过我写的一篇文章。那是 2014 年写的，叫《创建精美 UI 的七条规则》。
And it was sort of like the first stab at the most important things I had learned about visual design. As a total visual design beginner, as a much more like left brain analytical style thinker, it was just kind of a couple things that I had picked up on
那是我作为视觉设计初学者，作为更偏向左脑分析型思维的人，对我学到的关于视觉设计的最重要的事情的第一次尝试，只是我总结出的几点。
that I couldn't find anywhere else, just like really tactical advice. So I was like, okay, I'm going to publish this out here. And then I've continued writing about design since then. Definitely do UX and UI and even a little bit of front end development for all my clients now. So I really like that.
我在其他地方找不到这些建议，它们是非常实用的建议。所以我当时想，好吧，我要把它发布出来。从那以后，我一直在写关于设计的文章。现在我为所有客户做 UX、UI，甚至还有一点前端开发。所以我真的很喜欢这样。
So, yeah, that's kind of how I stumbled my way into design through like every other subfield in tech. Nice. So I have like a thousand questions, but OK. So first of all, so you mentioned UI versus UX thousand questions but okay so first of all so you mentioned uh ui versus ux so how do you kind of uh well first of all what do they mean and what do you mean by the difference oh geez yeah this is like a bad joke in design because it's like there's ux designers ui designers ux and ui designers product designers ux researchers
所以，是的，这就是我如何通过科技领域的其他子领域误打误撞进入设计行业的。太棒了。我有无数个问题，但好吧。首先，你提到了 UI 和 UX，那么它们到底意味着什么？你所说的区别是什么？天哪，这在设计界是个老梗了，因为有 UX 设计师、UI 设计师、UX 和 UI 设计师、产品设计师、UX 研究员
uh what else we got am i missing one interaction. There's so many. It's like, what do all these terms mean? I try and keep it really simple. I say UI is how it looks, user interface, that's how it looks. And UX, user experience, that's how it works. Is it usable? Is it intuitive? Is it simple and easy to use? So yeah. So you mentioned that, you know, you would try to draw these sketches of what it would look like that you call them wireframes. Can you maybe like describe so I've come across this before, but like, what kind of tooling do you use? And what it looked like? Were you actually sketching on a piece of paper? Or how are you getting started doing that? Oh, yeah. I mean, it always starts on paper, right? Because paper is the cheapest way to throw it like it's the cheapest way to design something, you can make a draft that you can visually evaluate yourself or show to one of
还有什么？我漏掉了一个吗？交互设计师。太多了。这些术语到底是什么意思？我尽量保持简单。我说 UI 是它看起来的样子，用户界面，就是外观。而 UX，用户体验，是它运作的方式。它好用吗？直观吗？简单易用吗？所以，是的。你提到你会尝试画出它看起来的样子，你称之为线框图。你能描述一下吗？我以前见过，但你用什么工具？它看起来是什么样的？你是真的在纸上画吗？还是怎么开始的？哦，是的。它总是从纸上开始，对吧？因为纸是抛弃想法最便宜的方式，它是设计东西最便宜的方式，你可以做一个草稿，自己进行视觉评估，或者展示给你的
your teammates. And you can do that in seconds, right? You can like get that validation of is this what we want to do even at the highest level or not. And once you've sketched a bunch of stuff out on paper, you know, it could be a couple ideas, it could be like 10, 20, 30, you're like, all right, now I think I have a good enough idea of what I want to go and put in a digital version of this wireframe. And so for those digital versions, back in the day, I was using Balsamiq. I've kind of transitioned over to using Sketch now, just because I also do the UI design in Sketch. But either of those apps are just fantastic apps. So for someone who's never built a UI before, so they do some coding, and all of a sudden they realize, oh, I really need a graphical user interface here rather than just command line. Although command line is great. What is the first
队友看。你可以在几秒钟内完成，对吧？即使在最高层面上，你也能验证这是否是我们想要做的。一旦你在纸上画了很多东西，可能是几个想法，可能是 10 个、20 个、30 个，你会想，好吧，现在我觉得我已经有足够好的想法，可以把它们做成数字版的线框图了。对于那些数字版本，过去我用 Balsamiq。我现在已经转用 Sketch 了，因为我也在 Sketch 里做 UI 设计。但这两个应用都是非常棒的工具。所以对于一个从未构建过 UI 的人来说，他们会写代码，突然意识到，哦，我真的需要一个图形用户界面，而不是命令行。虽然命令行很棒。他们应该尝试做的第一件事
thing for them to try doing? Should they sit down and start trying to do wireframes or should they try finding a framework to start doing all that in? Yeah. Well, I think fundamentally the wireframes is more important than the framework. Frameworks are great, but they almost come a little bit later in the process. Okay. So if you're taking the design process as a whole, where let's say you have some app, it's your side project, and you realize, okay, I'm officially in over my head. I need to make this interface. I've never really done this before. definitely doing those kind of low fidelity sketches and wireframes and just getting a sense of does this does you know if i lay things out in this way can i look at the most important tasks and each of those most important tasks are actually they like almost could not be made simpler they
是什么？他们应该坐下来开始尝试做线框图，还是应该尝试找一个框架来开始做这一切？嗯，我认为从根本上说，线框图比框架更重要。框架很棒，但它们在流程中出现得稍晚一些。好的。所以如果你把整个设计过程看作一个整体，假设你有一个应用，这是你的副业，你意识到，好吧，我正式力不从心了。我需要制作这个界面。我以前从未真正做过这个。绝对要进行那种低保真的草图和线框图绘制，并了解一下，如果我以这种方式布局，我能否看到最重要的任务，而每一个最重要的任务实际上几乎不能再简化了，它们
don't require any extra taps or clicks they don't require any extra thinking you just make them like as dead simple as possible and then the things that are important, those can kind of fade in the background. But that's what wireframes help with. When you get a wireframe, kind of run through some of those things in your own mind or show it to someone. Be like, hey, if you saw this screen and we wanted you to create
不需要额外的点击，不需要额外的思考，你只需要让它们尽可能简单，然后那些重要的东西可以淡化到背景中。但这就是线框图的帮助所在。当你得到一个线框图时，在脑海中过一遍这些事情，或者展示给别人看。说，嘿，如果你看到这个屏幕，我们想让你创建一个
a new user, how would you do that? A tap here. Wrong. It's like, shoot, okay, now I know I need to make that easier to see or whatever. So that's kind of where it starts. And that's just the UX side of things. When you get to the visual side of things, then it's a little bit different. And I can talk about that too.
新用户，你会怎么做？点这里。错了。就像，糟糕，好吧，现在我知道我需要让它更容易被看到，或者其他什么。所以这就是它开始的地方。这只是 UX 方面的事情。当你进入视觉方面时，情况就有点不同了。我也可以谈谈那个。
So I just did a look-see real quick. So Sketch is $100 a year. Unless you're a student, then it's $50 a year, which doesn't seem too bad if someone wants to try it and get started. I mean, it's cheaper than Photoshop. Oh, yeah. And I think it has a 30-day free trial, too. I might be wrong about that.
我刚才快速查了一下。Sketch 一年 100 美元。除非你是学生，那是 50 美元一年，如果有人想尝试并开始，这看起来不算太贵。我的意思是，它比 Photoshop 便宜。哦，是的。而且我想它也有 30 天的免费试用期。我可能记错了。
Yeah, you're right. You're right. So how do you draw the line? So you've kind of alluded that there's this difference between the interaction and the look. And you kind of described your arc through this giant collection of topics and fields. So someone just starting out, how important is it for them to mentally kind of make the distinction between the sort of style, the look versus the interaction? And which one do you think is better to go focus on first?
是的，你是对的。你是对的。那么你是如何划清界限的？你已经暗示了交互和外观之间存在差异。你描述了你跨越这一系列主题和领域的历程。所以对于刚入门的人来说，在心理上区分风格、外观和交互有多重要？你认为先专注于哪一个更好？
The interaction is better to focus on first. I mean, I think there is a degree to which if someone sees something that looks really just awful, they'll like next close the tab move on, they're not going to go download that app because they just don't think it's because you're signaling so strongly that it's just kind of like unprofessional or like, you know, if you if you give off these indicators in the visual design that it's not very high quality, like there was not a lot of professional experience put into something, it could drive some people away unless they really need and want that app and are otherwise excited about it. So there is some of that. But I think it's almost worse where someone goes
先专注于交互更好。我的意思是，如果有人看到看起来非常糟糕的东西，他们会直接关闭标签页离开，他们不会去下载那个应用，因为他们觉得这太不专业了，或者如果你在视觉设计中发出这些信号，表明它质量不高，没有投入很多专业经验，它可能会赶走一些人，除非他们真的需要并想要那个应用，否则他们会感到兴奋。所以确实有这方面的影响。但我认为更糟糕的是，有人
through the, you know, your site looks good enough and they download the app and they open it up. And then you make the tasks that they're going to be doing again and again in your app. You make those difficult and unintuitive and they just can't figure it out. That's almost worse. Because then they got so close and they're still going to end up abandoning you. So I think to be clear, making it usable, if people can't use it, like, it doesn't matter how look it, how nice it looks. Yeah, so in that sense, the usability and the UX are primary. kind of field that I've practiced most in. To hear you talk is so interesting to hear how different it is. So you mentioned, you know, first acquiring a user on a website, and then getting them to take some action, like download the app and do something and how thinking about that whole process. And it's literally so far away from anything that I do. It's actually very interesting to just hear
浏览了你的网站，觉得还行，然后下载了应用并打开它。然后你让他们在应用中反复执行的任务变得困难且不直观，他们根本搞不清楚。那几乎更糟糕。因为他们已经离成功那么近了，最后还是会放弃。所以我认为要明确一点，让它可用，如果人们无法使用它，它看起来再好也没用。是的，从这个意义上说，可用性和 UX 是首要的。这是我实践最多的领域。听你谈论这些非常有趣，听到它是多么不同。所以你提到了，你知道，首先在网站上获取用户，然后让他们采取行动，比如下载应用并做某事，以及如何思考整个过程。这实际上与我所做的任何事情都相去甚远。听到这些真的很令人感兴趣
how even though you know, oh, we can both be in a similar field, and just have such a different approach. So, you know, for me, it would be a developer, you know, we can both be in a similar field and just have such a different approach so you know for me it would be a developer you know getting an application i wrote and if it only had a command line interface that would probably be preferable or perfectly acceptable for them or it may just be computers calling it and to hear the amount of different things you talk about somewhat sounds overwhelming like oh i need to make a website to convince someone to use this yeah human beings are messy so how do you i mean do you feel that process so like you originally you know we're starting out as a coder and did some work there i imagine maybe a little similar to what i described and then moving out and sort of doing more on your
即使你知道，哦，我们可能都在相似的领域，却有如此不同的方法。所以，你知道，对我来说，作为一个开发者，你知道，获取我编写的应用程序，如果它只有一个命令行界面，那对他们来说可能更可取或完全可以接受，或者可能只是计算机在调用它。听到你谈论的这么多不同的事情，听起来有点让人不知所措，比如，哦，我需要做一个网站来说服别人使用它。是的，人类是混乱的。所以你是怎么，我的意思是，你觉得那个过程，比如你最初，你知道，开始时是一个程序员，并在那里做了一些工作，我想也许和我描述的有点相似，然后走出去，在某种程度上做更多
own and being responsible for that whole package do you feel like that was a really difficult change for you to do or did did that come pretty natural you? Jeez, you're making me think back. I think, you know, honestly, I think some of it was natural. I've always, even though the kind of the UI art school stuff seemed a little bit more foreign to me when I first started it, the whole like psychological challenge and kind of putting yourself in the mind of someone who's never seen your site before or seen your app before, I've always really enjoyed that.
自己的事情并对整个方案负责，你觉得那对你来说是一个非常困难的改变吗？还是说这很自然？天哪，你让我想起了过去。我想，老实说，我认为其中一些是自然的。我一直，尽管 UI 艺术学校的东西在我刚开始时对我来说似乎更陌生，但整个心理挑战，以及把自己放在一个从未见过你的网站或应用的人的思维中，我一直很享受这一点。
That's just been kind of this like deep mental challenge. So I think I kind of slid into that very naturally. And also, I mean, like I said, I also enjoyed the other parts of being a UX designer. Like, and we could talk about usability testing too, but like when you do usability testing, it's almost painful to watch someone, to make something that you think is so
这一直是一种深刻的心理挑战。所以我认为我非常自然地进入了那个状态。而且，我的意思是，就像我说的，我也很享受作为 UX 设计师的其他部分。比如，我们可以谈谈可用性测试，但当你进行可用性测试时，看着别人去使用你认为非常
good, so usable, so simple, right? And then you watch a video or you watch in person and someone struggles with it and just consistently misses everything you tried to make obvious and clear. And it's just, it's almost masochistic, but I kind of love that because it's like, you're not so smart. You really have to meet them where they are. And when I say you're not so smart, I'm referring to myself. I'm not referring to the user. In some sense, if you're not so smart. Like, you really have to meet them where they are. And when I say you're not so smart, I'm referring to myself. I'm not referring to the user. In some sense, if you're going to be a good UX designer, you have to realize that it's never the user's fault. Like, basically, coding docs aside,
好、好用、简单，对吧？然后你观看视频或亲自观察，有人在挣扎，并且始终错过了你试图让它变得明显和清晰的一切。这简直是受虐狂，但我有点喜欢它，因为这就像，你没那么聪明。你真的必须在他们所在的地方与他们会面。当我提到你没那么聪明时，我指的是我自己。我不是指用户。在某种意义上，如果你要成为一名优秀的 UX 设计师，你必须意识到这永远不是用户的错。就像，撇开编码文档不谈，
like, normal software just should not require manuals. And it's really sad to watch people, like, blame themselves when they use bad software to go, ah, dang, I did the wrong thing. I'm so bad at this. I'm so dumb. It's like, no, no, there should have been a designer doing their job because there are better ways to design software.
普通的软件不应该需要手册。看着人们在使用糟糕的软件时责怪自己，说，啊，该死，我做错了。我太不擅长这个了。我太笨了。这真的很令人难过。就像，不，不，应该有一个设计师在做他们的工作，因为有更好的方法来设计软件。
So that's fascinating. So I mean, those sound very valuable lessons, right? And stuff that I would probably be very embarrassed if someone had to sit down and use stuff I wrote. But so how do you, like, what would you go about in the beginning so you're early you don't have like this isn't your thing do you just like show it to friends and family like how do you get that user feedback yeah i mean so one of the blessings of working on little side projects is a lot of times you are the user and if you are the user you already understand some of the things that your users are going to know and not know when when you make this app for them um and you'll
这太迷人了。我的意思是，这些听起来是非常宝贵的经验，对吧？如果有人非要坐下来用我写的东西，我可能会感到非常尴尬。但你是怎么做的呢？比如，在刚开始的时候，你还处于早期阶段，这不是你的专长，你是直接展示给朋友和家人看吗？你是如何获得用户反馈的？嗯，我的意思是，做小项目的好处之一是，很多时候你就是用户。如果你是用户，当你为他们制作这个应用程序时，你已经了解了一些你的用户会知道和不知道的事情，而且你会
also be in a community of people who are kind of like similar mindsets so a lot of times yeah just show them to like friends family co-workers whoever it is uh like kind of doing that sort of guerrilla user testing really isn't it's not like you need to go do some official study and like, you know, it's nothing too fancy. You're just trying to get any feedback as to, like, is this basically usable? Or are people going to like absolutely struggle from square one?
也会处于一个思维方式相似的群体中。所以很多时候，是的，就把它们展示给朋友、家人、同事，随便谁都行。做那种游击式的用户测试真的不需要你去进行什么正式的研究，也不需要太花哨。你只是想获得任何反馈，比如，这东西基本能用吗？还是人们从一开始就会感到非常吃力？
One thing, it seems like a bit of a catch 22 or chicken and egg, I don't know, one of these things, they all sound the same to me, but where, you know, if you deploy version one of your app, and the user experience is really bad, then no one will try version two. But that means you can't make it better. Like, how do you kind of keep from getting trapped in that? Yeah, well, I think, again, there's something working in your favor, which is the people who are going to try version one anyways, are going to be the most desperate people to have that
有一件事，这似乎有点像进退两难，或者说是先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，我不知道，这些说法听起来都一样。就是说，如果你部署了应用程序的第一个版本，而用户体验真的很糟糕，那么就不会有人尝试第二个版本。但这又意味着你无法改进它。你是如何避免陷入这种困境的呢？嗯，我认为，同样地，有一件事对你有利，那就是无论如何都会尝试第一个版本的人，往往是那些最迫切需要解决该问题的人，
problem solved so they might be willing to put up with a little more pain and yeah it's like as soon as you identify there's issues with version 1 release version 2 because if you're like hey listen I heard y'all there's a lot of problems with version 1 and we're fixing them like download
所以他们可能愿意忍受更多的痛苦。是的，一旦你发现第一个版本有问题，就发布第二个版本，因为如果你说：“嘿，听着，我听到了你们的反馈，第一个版本有很多问题，我们正在修复它们，下载第二个版本吧，你会喜欢的。”那么那些即使在应用程序很难用、使用起来很困难的情况下仍然留下来的人，当你推出第二个版本时，他们会爱上它的。而且这种势头只会加速。所以，是的，这看起来确实像先有鸡还是先有蛋的问题，但我不认为这是无法解决的。
version 2 you're going to love it then the people who are staying with you, despite how unusable the app is and despite how difficult it is for them, they're going to just fall in love when you have version 2. And that's only going to accelerate. So yeah, it does seem like a chicken and an egg, but I don't think it's unmanageable. Yeah, it makes sense. If someone doesn't consider themselves a sort of artistic person or someone who uh would would not necessarily find themselves in the same circles with with kind
是的，这很有道理。如果一个人不认为自己是那种有艺术感的人，或者不认为自己会和那些有艺术气息的人处于同一个圈子里，你认为这会阻碍他们从事这项工作吗？你认为他们还能取得进步吗？这是一种后天习得的技能，还是天生的？嗯，我认为你绝对可以取得进步。我绝对是活生生的例子。我不能在播客上展示我的第一个设计，但它们看起来和我最近做的事情完全不同。所以从这个意义上说，是的，你绝对可以，绝对可以从中发展起来。而且我认为很酷的一点是，从来没有人真正告诉过我，如果你在网上阅读大量关于设计的文章，它看起来就像是那种“艺术装腔作势”，找不到更好的词来形容了，有点主观，你知道，还有所有这些神秘的考量，你永远不知道什么会奏效，它是
of artsy people does that kind of preclude them from this work do you think they can still make progress is that an acquired skill or something you're born with yeah well i think you absolutely can make progress with it like i'm definitely living proof of it i can't i can't show on a podcast my first design but they look nothing like the stuff that i've been doing very recently um so in that sense yeah you can absolutely um can absolutely develop at it and i think what's what's cool and what no one really ever told me is it's if you read a lot of design writing online it just seems like kind of artsy fartsy for lack of a better term like a little it's a little it's oh it's subjective oh uh you know there's still all these mystical considerations you never really know what's going to work it's
创造性的，开放式的。好吧，我想从技术上讲这些都是事实，但我认为你可以通过分析的方法在视觉设计上取得很大进展。所以，我强烈建议任何想投入时间提高视觉设计能力的人进行一项练习，仅仅是因为他们预见到，嘿，也许未来十年我每年都会有一个副业。或者也许我想创办自己的事业。当那一刻到来时，我真的希望能够做到，在雇佣设计师之前，先把视觉设计搞定。我强烈推荐的一个练习是做“临摹”。好的，我可以给你发一篇文章的链接，我为节目笔记写过关于这个的文章。但临摹就是，它是练习重新创造一个设计，
creative it's open-ended and it's like okay i guess technically those things are true but i think you can make a lot of traction on visual design just approaching it analytically. So like one exercise that I would highly recommend to anyone who wants to devote some time into visual design to get better at it, just because they anticipate, hey, maybe I'm going to have a side project a year for the next decade. Or maybe I want to start my own thing. And I really, you know, when that time comes along, I really want to be able to do the, like, just ace the visual design of it until I can hire a designer. One exercise I would highly recommend is do copywork. Okay, and I can send you a link to an article I wrote about this for the show notes. But copywork is just, it's, it is the practice of recreating a design
比你原本能做的要好，你逐像素地重新创造它。所以如果他们使用了比如 32 号的 Helvetica Bold 字体，你就把那个 Helvetica Bold 放在完全相同的位置。你可以使用像 Sketch 这样的应用程序，或者从技术上讲 Photoshop 或 Figma 等来做这件事，但核心思想是，通过重新创造这些由专业设计师（至少假设是这样）创作的设计，你会下意识地吸收他们所做的所有这些小技巧。所以我让我的所有学生都做这个练习，他们所意识到的事情令人惊叹。他们会说：“哦，我从来没有意识到对齐有多重要。”而且
that is better than you could do and you recreate it pixel for pixel so if they use like size 32 helvetica bold or whatever like you put that helvetica bold on their exact same font exact same location you can use an app like sketch or i mean technically photoshop or figma or whatever to do this but the idea is just by recreating these designs that were created by professional designers at least presumably you're going to be unconsciously picking up all these little tactics about what they do so I have all my students do this exercise and it's amazing the things that they recognize they're like oh I never realized how much alignment matters and it's
是的，这绝对是真的。对齐的重要性令人震惊，你永远不会预料到，直到你开始动手去做。或者，你知道，“哦，我尝试为这个元素制作阴影，但完全不起作用，直到我意识到他们为环境光加上了方向光阴影，或者类似的东西。”那有点高级，那是一个微小的细节。但这涵盖了所有的事情。在我写的那篇文章里，我记得提到过做一些临摹。
like yeah that's absolutely true it's mind-blowing how important alignment is you would just never expect it until you uh until you start to do it or um you know oh i tried to make this shadow for this element and it totally wasn't working until i realized they had a shadow for the ambient light plus a shadow for the directional light or something like that that's a little that's a little advanced that's a tiny detail. But it's just the whole gamut of things. In this article I wrote. I remember mentioning doing some copy work.
在一个名为 Epicurrence 的设计会议网站上。这个网站做的一件事是，它有一个 300 号的字体。虽然只有几个字母，但它几乎是一个艺术元素，然而它又是页面上的文字。我当时想：“哇，我甚至从来没想过要做 300 号大小的东西，但当他们这样做时，它看起来真的很酷。”所以，是的，你只是学到了这些小技巧，
On a site for Epicurrence. A design conference. And one thing that this site did. Was it had like this size 300 font. Where it was just a couple letters but it was like almost an artistic element and yet it was type on the page there were letters and i was like wow i would never have even thought ever to make something at size 300 and yet it looks really cool when they're doing this um so there's just yeah you just pick up these little tips and tricks
以及你从未预料到的事情，这就是临摹的妙处。然后，你在做这件事时发现的任何小策略，都可以应用到你自己的设计中。你开始，就像通过渗透一样。你会想：“好吧，这是那个人在做这件事时利用的经验教训。”当然，你会错过一些东西。
and things that you never would have expected and that's what's awesome about copywork is then any of those little strategies that you that you find in doing expected. And that's what's awesome about copy work is then any of those little strategies that you find in doing this, you can apply those to your own designs. And you start, it's just like by osmosis. You're like, okay, here's the lessons that this person utilized when doing it. And sure, you're gonna miss some stuff.
你不会理解设计师所做的每一个决定的基本原理，但你会比仅仅看着设计并试图说“好吧，我想设计一个像这样的东西”要学到多得多。祝你好运，这很难。这是一个非常棒的见解，因为我最近不知何故陷入了在 YouTube 上观看音乐理论视频的深渊，他们说了一些非常相似的话，
You're not gonna understand the rationale for every single decision the designer made, but you're gonna catch so much more than if you just look at the design and try and be like, okay, I wanna design something like this. It's good luck that is tough that's a really awesome insight because i have recently for some reason fallen into a rat hole of listening to music theory videos on youtube or watching sort of music theory videos and they say something very similar
基本上就是学习翻唱你最喜欢的艺术家，或者演奏经典作品，几乎和你给出的见解完全一样。但作为一名工程师，我发现现在我试图思考为什么它如此不同。也就是说，当我看到一个电子游戏（这是人们通常开始对编程产生兴趣的方式）时，你需要做多少事情才能从零开始让《毁灭战士》的所有部分工作，这简直是一座珠穆朗玛峰，你甚至不会真正尝试它。你可能会尝试，但你会做得非常糟糕。所以我想，也许这只是复杂程度的问题，我不确定，行为等等，但坐下来复制一段你真正喜欢的代码并不是一种常见的做法，或者至少不是
like basically learning to cover your favorite artist or you know play classics and almost you know sort of exactly the same insights you're you're sort of giving but as an engineer i find that now i'm trying to think of like kind of why it's so different which is you know when i see a video game which is how often people you know get started into interest in coding the amount of things you would need to do to sort of make a all the pieces of doom work from scratch is such a mount everest that you wouldn't even really attempt it you might attempt it but you would do terrible at it so i guess like maybe it's just the level of complexity like i'm not sure like the behavior all of that but it's not a common practice to sort of sit down and copy a piece of code you really like uh or at least not
在你所说的那个层面上。这只是一个直觉，但我不知道你是否可以缩小那个任务的规模。比如，拿一些像“整洁代码”实践的东西，我想知道你是否可以找到一个文件，不需要是整个项目，你只需要找到一个文件，你会觉得：“哇，这写得真好，非常整洁，我要逐行重新创建它，让它渗透进去。”看看他们是如何命名东西的，看看他们是如何做任何事情的。是的，这是一个好观点。是的，这很有道理。我认为你在大学里做的很多课程作业都是这样的，对吧？比如实现冒泡排序，实现快速排序，显然这些事情已经被做烂了，但是
at the level you're talking about this is just a hunch but i wonder if you could scale down that task so like take something like clean coding practices i wonder if you could like find a well just one file it doesn't have to be the whole project but you just find one file where you're like whoa this was really well written it's super clean i'm going to like recreate it line by line and just kind of let that soak in like see how they name stuff see how they whatever yeah that's a good point yeah that makes sense i think a lot of the a lot of the coursework you do in university is like this right it's like implement bubble sort implement quick sort and you know obviously those things have been done to death but
但这不仅仅是为了训练那个，但我感觉区别在于，它们是……无论你怎么称呼它，我想就像武术中的“型”或者其他什么，它们专门是为了学习那些你指出的东西。它们不像是在复制杰作或复制灵感。没有人会因为学习归并排序是如何工作的而受到启发去继续编程。是的，也许一个人会，但不多。所以这很有道理。是的，我想知道随着我们领域里的人越来越多，总是有一种推动力，你知道，让人们在各个方面都能进行编程。我想知道我们是否会开始转向寻找让人们受到启发的方法，让他们真正能够做到这一点，因为起初感觉就是：“哇，我做的这个东西完全是衍生品。”但当你刚开始设计时，我的意思是，见鬼，即使当你设计水平更高时，我也非常怀疑我做的任何事情是我没在别处见过的。只是我借鉴的来源数量非常多，所以它不像是在抄袭某一样东西。它是在抄袭 20 或 30 样东西，只是为了某个随机的网站。这就是创造力，混合和匹配以做出
but it's not just trying to train that but i feel like the difference is slightly they're uh whatever you would call it and i guess like martial arts like katas or whatever like they're specifically for the purpose of learning those things you're indicating they're not sort of like copy a masterpiece or copy a piece of inspiration like no one will be inspired to continue encoding by learning how merge sort works yeah maybe one person but not many people yeah so that makes sense yeah i wonder as we get more and more people uh in the field right like trying there's always this push to you know, enable people to do coding just in various aspects. I wonder if we'll start to have to turn to finding ways of getting people inspired where they really can make about that, like, because that's how it feels at first to just be like, wow, this is this thing I made is completely derivative. But so when you're first starting out in design, and I mean, heck, even when you're when you're much more advanced in design, it's like, I highly doubt I'm doing much of anything that I haven't seen somewhere. It's just that the number of sources that I draw from is so large that it's not like copying off of one thing. It's copying off of like 20 or 30 things for just, you know, some random website. And that's like, that's what creativity is mixing and matching to make
解决问题的最佳方案。所以如果你刚开始设计，是的，感觉可能有点像：“哦，我只是在抄袭这一个东西。”好吧，没关系，找到更多你喜欢的作品，试着找出你喜欢的每一个作品的不同方面，这样你就可以把它们结合在一起。我不建议直接去 stripe.com
the most of whatever the problem like to, to make the best solution to the problem that you have. So if you're just starting out in design, yeah, it might feel kind of like, oh, I'm just like copying off this one thing. Well, okay, find more things that you like and try and figure out the different aspects that you like of each one so you can kind of combine them into one. I don't recommend just like going to stripe.com
然后说：“哇，这看起来太棒了。我要使用完全相同的按钮，完全相同的页面品牌。”不要那样做。但是，是的，真正喜欢其他风格并将它们的方面结合起来是可以的。还有一件事我听说过，我也告诉我的学生，如果你担心你太过于模仿某一个人的风格，抄袭得太严重了，那么好吧，看看那个，吸收他们做得好的所有东西，关掉那个标签页或应用程序，第二天开始你的设计，不要再看它了。不要看灵感来源，所以设计时只
and being like, wow, this looks awesome. I'm going to use the same exact buttons, the same exact page brands, you page. Don't do that. But yeah, it's okay to really like other styles and to combine aspects of those. And one other thing I've heard, and I tell my students this too, is if you're worried that you're too much aping one person's style, you're copying off one style too heavily, it's like okay look at that soak up all the stuff that they did good that they did well close that tab or close that app or whatever and then the next day begin your design and don't look at it again don't look at the inspiration so like design but only
通过你隔夜吸收的东西，而不是说你不被允许直接看着他们的然后制作你的，然后交叉检查他们的并编辑你的。所以如果你认为你的设计太过于基于某一个人的风格，这些东西都会有帮助。是的，这很有道理。最近有没有哪个网站或应用程序让你觉得：“哇，那真是令人难以置信的新颖、惊人的设计”？是的，最近的一个。我实际上刚刚写了一篇博客文章，或者说是发给我时事通讯的一封邮件，但后来我也把它作为博客文章发布了。它是在一个健康网站上，叫什么来着，让我快速查一下。它在哪里？
through what you kind of soaked up overnight not like you're not allowed to like just look at theirs and then make yours then cross check theirs and edit yours or whatever so that stuff will all help with if you think your designs are like too much based on one person's style yeah that makes sense what is a like a website or an app where you just said wow that was unbelievably like novel amazing design uh recently yeah yeah recent one. So I actually just wrote a blog post, or it was an email to my newsletter, but then I posted it as a blog post too. And it was on a health website called, let me pull it up here real quick. Where is it?
很疯狂，我不记得它的名字了，但我写了大约一千字关于它的文章，Foundation Medicine，所以就是 foundationmedicine.com。但这是一个网站，当我加载它时，我心想：“哇，他们把很多事情做得非常好。”现在我们都在电脑上疯狂地搜索。哦，是的，它看起来很酷，他们开始在那位女士的脸上画那些三角形。是的，有很好的动画，有高质量的摄影，字体非常好。我在博客文章中谈到的一点是，他们有一种六边形的主题，你在整个网站中一遍又一遍地看到这种图案，它把一切联系在一起。但你看，徽标里有这个六边形，然后你看，他们画了这些三角形，当然这些三角形组成了六边形。如果你看字体，看看那个 e，甚至
It's crazy that I can't remember the name of it, and yet I wrote like thousand words about it foundation medicine so just foundationmedicine.com but this is one site that when I loaded up I was like wow they did a lot of things very well now we're all going furiously on our computers oh yeah it looks cool they start drawing those triangles on that lady's face yeah there's like nice animation there's high quality photography the fonts are really nice like the thing i talk about in my blog post on this is um they kind of have this motif of hexagons like you see this pattern again and again throughout the site and it kind of ties it together but you look there's like this hexagon and the logo and then you look and they have the they draw these triangles which of course make hexagons and then if you look at the fonts like look at um see it kind of in the e or even the
s 的形状，很多小写字母的形状更像六边形而不是椭圆形。哦，是的。所以你会看到它，你向下滚动，你会看到它，比如那个小 DNA 的东西，或者在“Better Care Today”下面，有一个 1 和一个 2，它们都嵌入在普通的六边形中。所以这个小主题一遍又一遍地出现。我的意思是，他们不仅做了一千个其他好的设计选择，而且关于这个非常酷的一点是，他们把一切联系在一起，让它看起来非常有目的性，就像一个整体一样。是的，这太棒了。所以当你去这样一个网站，像你指出的那些东西，这太棒了，因为如果不是你指出，我甚至不会注意到那些字体是微妙地倾斜的，也不会注意到他们的徽标是一个六边形。
shape of the s a lot of those lowercase letters are sort of shaped like hexagons more than ovals oh yeah so and you'll see it you scroll down and you're gonna see it like with the little dna thing or um under better care today there's a one and a two which are both embedded in just plain old hexagons so it's just like this little motif comes up again and again and um i mean not only did they make a thousand other good design choices but one thing that's very cool about this is they tie it all together and make it look very intentional and like act as one whole yeah this is awesome so when you go to a website like this and like those things you point out that's awesome because i wouldn't have even noticed that those fonts are subtly angled until you point that out that their logo was a hexagon like i didn't
我甚至没有注意到，当我看着它的时候。但我的意思是，我同意，你看着这个，你会想：“哦，这看起来真的很酷。”所以你是如何，我想称之为“自力更生”，从“我没有这种审美眼光”开始的呢？你知道，我去这里，我想：“伙计，好吧，我知道当我看到它时，它看起来不错。”但我不知道如何分解它。有没有一种好的方法来开始，看什么，做什么？我想你刚才提到了尝试复制它，也许如果你尝试复制它，你就会弄明白。让我们，我的意思是，让我们从那之前开始。你想谈谈你应该从第一天开始做什么吗？因为关于六边形的那一点，那绝对不是 101 级别的设计知识。
even notice that when i looked at it uh but i mean i agree you look at this you're like oh this looks really cool so how do you sort of i guess i would call it bootstrap yourself up from like i have no eye for this aesthetic you know i go here i'm like man okay i know when i see it like it looks good but i wouldn't know how to sort of decompose this like is there a good method for sort of starting and what to look at what to do i guess you were kind of mentioned you know trying to copy it and maybe you would sort of figure it out if you tried copying it let's let's i mean let's back it up even from there you want to talk about what you should do from day one because certainly the the bit about the hexagons like that is not 101 level like design knowledge.
我甚至不会指望我的学生去某个网站就能注意到这一点。所以那些真正更基础的东西是，我会说，当你看到你喜欢的东西时，试着分析你为什么喜欢它。还要看看你是否能找到一些例子，它们有点像，我不知道“反事实”这个词是否正确，但它们没有那种特定的品质，而你就不那么喜欢那个网站了。试着找到对一个网站看起来不错至关重要的东西。比如这个 Foundation Medicine 网站的一件事是，我的猜测是那张盯着我的大脸，那张高质量的照片，如果我使用了一张质量较低、没有对焦的照片
I wouldn't expect even my students to like just notice that going to some site. So the stuff that really is kind of more foundational is I would say just analyzing when you see something you like, trying to analyze why you like it. And also see if you can find examples that are kind of like, I don't know if counterfactuals is the right word, but like they don't have that particular quality and you don't like the site as much. Like try and find something that is critical to a particular site looking good. So like one thing with this foundation medicine site is my guess is that big face staring at me, that high-quality photo, if I used a lower-quality photo that wasn't in focus
或者也许是彩色的，我想它们都是黑白的。是这样吗？是的，没错。那行不通，它看起来会太多，或者上面的黄色三角形看起来会很奇怪
or that was maybe in color, I think they're all black and white. Is that true? Yeah, that's right. That that wouldn't work, that it would look too much, it would be too much, or the yellow triangles over it would then look weird
而且不会那么突出，可能会弄乱那个人的皮肤颜色或者类似的东西。你只是无法很好地看到它们。是的，看起来像针灸之类的。是的，或者你可能会。是的，看起来像某种可怕的酷刑。或者我可能会假设，好吧，这是很酷的字体。我甚至不知道它在这里叫什么。我只是去使用我的 WhatFont 浏览器扩展。它是 GT Sectra。好的，GT Sectra。那很酷。
and wouldn't stand out as much and would maybe mess with the color of the person's skin too or something like that. You just wouldn't see them as well. Yeah, it looked like acupuncture or something. Yeah, or you might. Yeah, it looked like some terrible torture. Or I might hypothesize that, okay, here's this cool font. I don't even know what it's called here. I'll just go use my what font browser extension. It's GT Sectra. Okay, GT Sectra. That's cool.
那很酷。
What do I think works about this font? Even if I don't recognize the hexagonal stuff, maybe it needs to be a serif. Maybe it needs to be a serif because this has to have a very professional, buttoned-up feel, almost like research-like. And so just something that's one of those high-quality, just a font that feels trustworthy and almost prestigious or something,
我觉得这个字体好在哪里呢？即使我认不出那些六边形的东西，也许它需要用衬线体。也许它需要用衬线体，因为这必须给人一种非常专业、严谨的感觉，就像研究报告一样。所以，这只是一种高质量的、让人觉得值得信赖、甚至有些尊贵感的字体。
and delicate, that's what I want. And I could go and test that by putting in whatever, Helvetica, or even a nice sans-serif like Proxima Nova or Gotham or something, which I think they use one of those elsewhere on the page. And I could check. I mean, especially if you can use the little dev tools in your browser and just kind of start swapping things out or mess around with the site, see what ruins it. See what ruins the feel where you're like, oh, yeah, this isn't as good. And you can start to analyze. OK, so this is what the what this is, what the the goodness of the design's appearance relies on.
精致，这就是我想要的。我可以去测试一下，比如换上 Helvetica，或者像 Proxima Nova 或 Gotham 这样漂亮的无衬线字体，我想他们在页面的其他地方可能就用了其中一种。我可以去核实一下。我的意思是，特别是如果你能使用浏览器里的开发者工具，开始替换一些东西，或者摆弄一下网站，看看是什么破坏了它的感觉。看看是什么破坏了那种感觉，让你觉得“哦，是的，这没那么好了”。然后你就可以开始分析了。好吧，这就是设计外观的优良之处所依赖的东西。
It relies on this font being serif and large and looking this nice at a big size. It relies on these photographs being extremely high quality and black and white. One of the big things that you'll discover in doing this sort of exercise, like I mentioned it once before, but alignment is huge. Like you are almost certainly, if you're a beginning designer, you are almost certainly underestimating how important alignment is and how much you just need to align everything on the page. At least if you want kind of a neat, simple, clean appearance. Basically every element will be aligned with at least one other element. And when I say that centering counts as a form of alignment in that regard. So centered or aligned with other elements, that's huge.
它依赖于这种字体是衬线体，字号很大，而且在大尺寸下看起来很漂亮。它依赖于这些照片具有极高的质量，并且是黑白的。在做这类练习时，你会发现的一件大事，就像我之前提到过的那样，就是对齐非常重要。如果你是一个初学者，你几乎肯定低估了对齐的重要性，以及你需要将页面上的所有东西都对齐的程度。至少如果你想要一种整洁、简单、干净的外观的话。基本上每个元素都至少要与另一个元素对齐。当我说这句话时，居中在某种程度上也算是一种对齐方式。所以，居中或者与其他元素对齐，这非常重要。
You could say similar things about white space. I'm on a Mac, so I can just press whatever it is, Shift-Control-Command-4 is the little hotkey I use. Like I'm going to go take a photo. Oh, my keyboard shut off. Well, I think that's it. And I can get a little measurer that'll say if you press that that uh hotkey you'll get a little it'll tell you how big of a rectangle you're clicking and dragging on your screen and you can i use that to really quickly
关于留白，你也可以说类似的话。我在用 Mac，所以我可以直接按下快捷键，我用的快捷键是 Shift-Control-Command-4。就像我要去拍张照一样。哦，我的键盘关掉了。好吧，我想就是这样。我可以拿一个测量工具，如果你按下那个快捷键，它会告诉你你在屏幕上点击和拖动的是多大的矩形，我可以用它来非常快速地
make measurements of how big something is how tall is this header it's like well how tall is a normal header took me a while and then i realized okay it seems like most headers are like on the order of 70 pixels um and maybe they'll get a little bit bigger maybe if it's an extra space dot website they'll be bigger if there's a version that is sticky when i scroll down the page it might be a smaller version but like 70 pixels okay just a good place to start or like go look at um at some kind of a division of this page, this foundationmedicine.com. It's like how much white space is between, say, the where it has the one to comprehensive genomic profiling, and then that orange box below it. It's like, on my page, that might be like 70 or 100 pixels. And until you measure that, here, I'm actually going to go see. I want to see what it is.
测量某个东西有多大，这个标题有多高？就像，正常的标题有多高？我花了一段时间，然后我意识到，好吧，大多数标题似乎都在 70 像素左右。嗯，也许它们会大一点，如果是一个 Extra Space 网站，它们可能会更大。如果有一个版本在我向下滚动页面时是悬浮的，它可能是一个较小的版本，但 70 像素左右，好吧，这是一个很好的起点。或者去看看这个页面的某种划分，比如 foundationmedicine.com。就像，在“Comprehensive Genomic Profiling”所在的位置和它下面的那个橙色方框之间有多少留白。在我的页面上，那可能是 70 或 100 像素。在你测量它之前，这里，我实际上要去看看。我想看看它到底是多少。
Yeah, one thing I noticed is the... Ah, it is 180. Okay, to be fair, I'm looking at a different monitor. It's 180 pixels of white space. And so one thing is like, if you were in Sketch, or even if you were in CSS,
是的，我注意到的一件事是……啊，是 180。好吧，公平地说，我是在看另一台显示器。那是 180 像素的留白。所以有一件事是，如果你在 Sketch 里，或者即使你在 CSS 里，
but you really shouldn't try and do all your visual design from CSS, disclaimer. It's like, if you were in CSS, would you write margin bottom 180 pixels like that seems like an absurdly large number and as a beginning visual designer i would be like no it can just be like 50 or something or 48 why not make it divisible but like um the point is when you kind of design visual first and you really analyze what you like and and what seems to be
但你真的不应该尝试用 CSS 完成所有的视觉设计，免责声明。就像，如果你在 CSS 里，你会写 margin-bottom: 180px 吗？这看起来是一个荒谬的大数字。作为一个视觉设计初学者，我会说不，它可能只是 50 左右或者 48，为什么不让它可整除呢？但重点是，当你先进行视觉设计，并真正分析你喜欢什么，以及什么似乎是
important about it you're gonna find all these things wow they align so much more than i thought wow they stuff in so much white space and it's not even crazy um and so on yeah they made those two the the picture and then the orange box are at different heights and that way it doesn't just make a big rectangle it kind of keeps them distinct yeah they do that's true yeah this is this is awesome, it kind of keeps them distinct. Yeah, they do. That's true. Yeah, this is awesome. And they kind of do that throughout, right? Even their little link to their blog towards the bottom, where there's no picture, they have that same motif repeated with the little...
重要的，你会发现所有这些东西，哇，它们对齐得比我想象的要多得多，哇，他们塞进了这么多留白，而且这甚至并不疯狂。嗯，等等，是的，他们把那两个东西——图片和橙色方框——放在了不同的高度，这样它就不会只是形成一个大矩形，它让它们保持了独立。是的，他们确实这样做了，这是真的。是的，这太棒了，它让它们保持了独立。是的，他们确实这样做了。这是真的。是的，这太棒了。而且他们似乎在整个页面中都这样做，对吧？即使是他们底部指向博客的小链接，那里没有图片，他们也重复了同样的图案，带有那个小……
Yeah, right. Yep. And even the, you could say the same thing happens at the very top where they have the header image. It's like there's a white rectangle coming in from the bottom sort of cutting off. It's a oh yeah yeah yeah so just hearing you sort of like describe this i already feel myself uh brightening at the kind of interesting things you could go in here and do and measure and i want to try myself and we we mentioned this a little bit in this sort of
是的，没错。是的。甚至，你也可以说同样的事情发生在最顶部，他们有页眉图片的地方。就像底部有一个白色的矩形进来，某种程度上切断了它。哦，是的，是的，是的。所以听到你这样描述，我已经感觉到自己因为你可以进去做和测量的那些有趣的事情而变得兴奋起来，我想亲自尝试一下。我们之前在节目开始前的热身中稍微提到了这一点，
warm-up before the show we were talking about uh this notion of like a place to go listen and just hear how designers talk. Like, do you have any good resources for people or recommendation? I know you have some stuff. Are there like, who do you go to just hear how this stuff works and how people think and what they talk through when they sort of decompose a website or any related topic? Oh, yeah. Well, I mean, my biggest recommendation is well, let me give the free one first. So I have a blog. It's mainly about visual design, learnui.design.blog. And there's a number of posts that really break down visual design in this kind of an analytical way.
我们谈到了这种“去听听设计师们如何交谈”的地方。你有什么好的资源或推荐给人们吗？我知道你有一些东西。有没有什么人，你去找谁来听听这些东西是如何运作的，人们是如何思考的，以及当他们分解一个网站或任何相关主题时，他们会讨论什么？哦，是的。嗯，我的最大推荐是，好吧，让我先说免费的那个。我有一个博客。它主要是关于视觉设计的，learnui.design.blog。上面有很多文章，以这种分析的方式真正剖析了视觉设计。
Like we've been talking about it right now. We haven't, I would like to believe we haven't really been talking about anything that's too fuzzy or crazy. So you can go there and you can find a lot of stuff. But also I have a course and it's linked from the same site, learnui.design. The name of the course is learnui.design. And one of kind of my teaching principles in making this course was just letting it be sort of a place where when a student logs on, it's a video course. So they basically look over my shoulder for like 20 hours of video as I'm just kind of
就像我们现在谈论的那样。我愿意相信我们并没有谈论任何太模糊或疯狂的东西。所以你可以去那里，找到很多东西。但我也有一门课程，链接就在同一个网站上，learnui.design。课程的名字叫 Learn UI Design。我在制作这门课程时的教学原则之一，就是让它成为一个学生登录后，这是一个视频课程。所以他们基本上是在看我的肩膀，看了大约 20 小时的视频，我只是在
narrating the stuff that I would think about. And then all the videos are done in sort of a manner of like real world projects. Some of them are directly based on client projects I've had. Some of them are a little bit made up. But the idea is each project tries to sort of talk about one particular skill that that lesson is about. So that is one option. But certainly for just diving in right at the start, the free option is like, check out,
叙述我会考虑的事情。所有的视频都是以真实世界项目的方式完成的。其中一些直接基于我做过的客户项目。其中一些是虚构的。但想法是，每个项目都试图讨论该课程所涉及的特定技能。所以这是一个选择。但当然，对于刚开始深入学习的人来说，免费的选择是，去看看，
check out my blog. And as for like, where I hear this, probably it's like, I'm a freelancer. So I am, I mean, I'm currently in my home office. There's, there's technically a couple designers across the street from me, but we don't actually talk about this stuff super often. So one of the biggest places where I hear it is in my own, in the Learn UI Design student community. It's just a Slack group, but we've got a lot of students now who are going out there and analyzing sites that they like and don't like, and bringing back these little tactics, and hey, I noticed this, or I noticed that, or why does this look does this look so good or why doesn't this look good so for me that's where i get some of this so for this field like you mentioned you know kind of like slack rooms or for other stuff you'd
去看看我的博客。至于我在哪里听到这些，可能是我是一个自由职业者。所以，我是说，我现在在我的家庭办公室里。技术上来说，街对面有几个设计师，但我们实际上并不经常谈论这些东西。所以我听到这些最大的地方之一是在我自己的 Learn UI Design 学生社区里。那只是一个 Slack 群组，但我们现在有很多学生，他们会去分析他们喜欢和不喜欢的网站，并带回这些小技巧，嘿，我注意到了这个，或者我注意到了那个，或者为什么这个看起来这么好，或者为什么这个看起来不好。所以对我来说，这就是我获得这些信息的地方。所以对于这个领域，就像你提到的，你知道，类似于 Slack 聊天室或其他东西，你会
hear oh maybe there's a subreddit where people do this or or something else do you feel like are there sort of schools of thought here that people sort of fall into lines like oh analytical analysis is really good or no no no you can't there's no rules just break all the rules like are there kind of different factions within design and how this works or it's pretty much everybody approach it in a in a similar manner i don't know i mean maybe my answer is i'm coming from one end of the spectrum here like uh in that when i learned visual design i was so frustrated where it's like, okay, I started out awful with colors. And if you look at some of my first designs, it's like the two colors I would use would be kind of a yellowish green that in retrospect looks kind of pukey and like brown.
听到，哦，也许有一个 subreddit 人们会这样做，或者其他什么。你觉得这里有人们倾向于遵循的流派吗？比如“分析法真的很好”，或者“不不不，你不能这样做，没有规则，打破所有规则”。设计内部有不同的派别吗？它是如何运作的？还是每个人都以类似的方式处理它？我不知道，我的意思是，也许我的回答是我正处于这个光谱的一端。因为当我学习视觉设计时，我非常沮丧，就像，好吧，我刚开始时颜色用得太糟糕了。如果你看看我最初的一些设计，我使用的两种颜色会是一种黄绿色，回想起来看起来有点像呕吐物，还有棕色。
It's like you can't have two grosser colors. And if you look at most professional designed apps, it's like I'm not designing like a theme for a sewer, right? Like if you look at most professional designed apps, you're not going to see brown. And you're not very often going to see yellow green. You're more often going to see something that's a bright yellow or a golden yellow or even just an orange. And brown is really going to be an accent color at most. It's hardly ever a theme color. Yeah, I think at one point I noticed almost all the websites were blue. Yes.
就像你不能有两种更恶心的颜色了。如果你看看大多数专业设计的应用程序，就像我不是在为下水道设计主题，对吧？如果你看看大多数专业设计的应用程序，你不会看到棕色。而且你也不会经常看到黄绿色。你更经常看到的是明亮的黄色、金黄色，甚至是橙色。棕色最多只能是强调色。它几乎从来不是主题色。是的，我想有一次我注意到几乎所有的网站都是蓝色的。是的。
It just seems like Microsoft's blue. Yeah, all the company websites seem to be blue well blue blue is we can talk about this too because if your audience has a lot of like side projects where they need to pick a color for a logo or just kind of go with a one color theme um that choice that choice is important and and so what's happening is when people pick blue blue like so let me back up one second here okay if you google for this stuff you're gonna find a lot on the psychology of colors. And as far as I can tell, all that stuff is completely bogus. There's stuff that's like, okay, yellow means trustworthiness. I don't know what it is.
这看起来就像微软的蓝色。是的，所有的公司网站似乎都是蓝色的。嗯，蓝色是……我们也可以谈谈这个，因为如果你的听众有很多副业，他们需要为标志选择颜色，或者只是选择一个单色主题，嗯，那个选择很重要。所以发生的情况是，当人们选择蓝色时……让我退后一步，好吧，如果你在谷歌上搜索这些东西，你会发现很多关于色彩心理学的内容。据我所知，所有这些东西都是完全虚假的。有些东西说，好吧，黄色意味着值得信赖。我不知道它是什么。
Yellow means passion, right? And then they'll show some yellow logos like Shell, like the gas station. It's like, no, this is not yellow for passion. This is yellow because it's a seashell what other color would you make a seashell um and so it's like that stuff just didn't help it was so frustrating and so i've tried to like analyze what works and and what doesn't work and only write that kind of content and one thing i think I've landed on with this color, picking a one color for your app,
黄色意味着激情，对吧？然后他们会展示一些黄色的标志，比如壳牌，比如加油站。就像，不，这不是为了激情的黄色。这是黄色，因为它是一个贝壳，你还能把贝壳做成什么颜色呢？所以，那些东西根本没有帮助，太令人沮丧了。所以我尝试分析什么有效，什么无效，并且只写那种内容。关于颜色，为你的应用程序选择一种颜色，我想我得出了一个结论，
blue is the safe choice. Blue is a practical choice because in terms of the, if you talk about kind of the natural luminosity or the sort of the natural brightness or lightness of a particular color, it's like yellows are all very bright. You can't have a dark yellow. It just becomes brown.
蓝色是安全的选择。蓝色是一个实用的选择，因为在……如果你谈论某种颜色的自然发光度或某种自然的亮度或明度，就像黄色都非常亮。你不能有深黄色。它只会变成棕色。
We don't even have a thought for dark yellow. That's not a thing. But blues can really span a big gamut. And blues can naturally be quite dark. And that's really nice because it stands out from white. So you can have, say, like a link be blue. And even if you have dark gray text, a blue link is actually, it's going to hold its own. It's not just going to be, like imagine if all your your links were yellow they would look like little gaps in the page if you
我们甚至没有深黄色的概念。那不是一回事。但蓝色确实可以跨越很大的色域。而且蓝色天生可以非常深。这真的很好，因为它在白色中很突出。所以你可以让链接变成蓝色。即使你有深灰色的文字，蓝色链接实际上也能保持自己的地位。它不会只是……想象一下，如果你的所有链接都是黄色的，它们看起来就像页面上的小缺口。如果你
just had a paragraph of text with some links in it those yellow links would just if you squinted they would just disappear so like blue is a very practical color blue is a very safe color it's a very universal color it doesn't it's not like red red is the most eye-catching color that's probably the most important thing to know about red so if you you pick red for your app's color, you're going to be competing with every normal red element in your page every time you actually need to get a user's attention. Every time you actually need to show them an error message
只有一段带有链接的文字，那些黄色链接如果眯起眼睛看，它们就会消失。所以蓝色是一种非常实用的颜色，蓝色是一种非常安全的颜色，它是一种非常通用的颜色。它不像红色，红色是最引人注目的颜色，这可能是关于红色最重要的事情。所以如果你为你的应用程序颜色选择了红色，你每次真正需要引起用户注意时，都要与页面上所有正常的红色元素竞争。每次你真正需要向他们显示错误消息时，
or kind of, you know, maybe they filled out a form wrong or something and you want to show a little message telling them that. It's like, you're also competing with, if you have a red header, that. And a red logo, that. uh other red elements interesting yeah it's just like it's like it's just shouting um it's like a miracle that the youtube mobile app kind of works at all because they just have a ton of red and yet it
或者，你知道，也许他们填错了表格之类的，你想显示一条小消息告诉他们。就像，你也在与……如果你有一个红色标题，那个。还有一个红色标志，那个。其他红色元素。有趣，是的，这就像……这就像在尖叫。YouTube 移动应用程序能运行简直是个奇迹，因为他们有大量的红色，然而它
seems to work fine so yeah they have that uh you know if something goes wrong in youtube they take to that page or it has a i think it says something like patrick you'd probably, but it says something like a team of monkeys is working to fix it. I mean, they just, they just have to take you to a whole new website because yeah, you wouldn't be able to see it. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. That's one way around it. Um, I remember when I was first working on one of the color videos for learn UI design, I was like, how does Airbnb solve this? Cause they kind of have, it's a little bit of a pinkish red and and it's not so saturated. It's not so rich. So it's not in your face, but it's like, what do they actually use for error messages? And I looked, and their solution, which was kind of surprising, and it might have changed over time, is they basically make it impossible for you to
似乎运行得很好。所以是的，他们有那个……你知道，如果 YouTube 出错了，他们会跳转到那个页面，或者它有一个……我想它写着类似“Patrick，你可能……”的东西，但它写着类似“一群猴子正在努力修复它”。我的意思是，他们只是不得不把你带到一个全新的网站，因为是的，你根本看不到它。是的。是的，完全正确。这是一种解决方法。嗯，我记得当我第一次制作 Learn UI Design 的颜色视频之一时，我在想，Airbnb 是怎么解决这个问题的？因为他们有一种……它有点偏粉红色，而且饱和度没那么高。它没那么浓郁。所以它不会让你感到不适，但我在想，他们实际上用什么来显示错误消息？我看了看，他们的解决方案，有点令人惊讶，而且可能随着时间推移有所改变，他们基本上让你不可能
see an error message. They just so carefully, like, choose what you can type, what you can't type, what you can select, so that it's very, very difficult to get into an error state. I basically, like, could not find one. Maybe there was one where they used orange. And it's like, oh, I wouldn't have thought of that. But that's suitably far away from kind of your pink-red. And it also looks good with it.
看到错误消息。他们非常小心地选择你可以输入什么，不可以输入什么，你可以选择什么，这样就很难进入错误状态。我基本上找不到一个。也许有一个他们用了橙色。就像，哦，我没想到这一点。但这与你的粉红色相当远。而且它看起来也很好。
So why not? so there's logic to these things right that's the i mean that's the point of what i'm saying is we just talked about the practical reasons for choosing blue um the practical reasons for choosing or not choosing red how to deal with error messages if you did choose red uh so there are rationales uh kind of like underlying so much of this stuff and it was just very frustrating for me as a beginning designer because it was like no one is saying these things. Like I have to discover each of these for myself. Yeah, I mean, that's one really interesting thing. I always thought that, I mean, until we had this discussion, that there was like a really strong element of voluntarism.
所以为什么不呢？所以这些事情是有逻辑的，对吧？这就是……我的意思是，这就是我所说的重点。我们刚刚谈到了选择蓝色的实际原因，选择或不选择红色的实际原因，如果你选择了红色，如何处理错误消息。所以这些东西背后都有基本原理。作为一个初学者，这对我来说非常令人沮丧，因为就像没有人说这些话。我必须自己去发现每一个。是的，我的意思是，这是一件非常有趣的事情。我一直认为，我的意思是，在我们进行这次讨论之前，我认为有一种非常强烈的志愿主义元素。
That basically you could do whatever you wanted. But what you're saying is like, no, if you just randomly pick colors, especially like all the primary colors, then your website will look like a five-year-old built your website. Yeah, which sometimes, I mean, if you're making a website that just needs to be really friendly and maybe like kid-friendly or aimed at kids too, it's like, great, do pick all the primary colors. That'll work fantastically and it'll signal exactly who the website is for. But I would say that it's actually you said volunteerism i'm not totally sure what that means but it just means like you do whatever you want and it'll just work okay so it's kind of halfway in between i would say you can do whatever you want as long as you have at least one solid reason for it um and sometimes and sometimes your solid reason is like let's say you're making like a website for an environmental non-profit guess what every environmental non-profit has is their theme color green green so what if your rationale was i'm going to pick something that is not green it could
基本上你可以做任何你想做的事。但你所说的是，不，如果你只是随机选择颜色，特别是像所有原色，那么你的网站看起来就像一个五岁小孩建的。是的，有时候，我的意思是，如果你制作的网站只需要非常友好，也许像对孩子友好，或者也针对孩子，就像，太好了，选择所有的原色。那会非常棒，而且它会准确地传达网站是为谁准备的。但我会说，实际上你说了“志愿主义”，我不完全确定那是什么意思，但它只是意味着你做任何你想做的事，它就会奏效。好吧，所以我认为它介于两者之间。我会说你可以做任何你想做的事，只要你至少有一个充分的理由。嗯，有时候，有时候你的充分理由是，假设你正在为一个环保非营利组织制作网站，猜猜每个环保非营利组织的主题颜色是什么？绿色。绿色。所以如果你的理由是“我要选择一种不是绿色的颜色”，它可能
and in that sense yeah there's going to be some things that you shouldn't make it um perhaps but it gives you so much more leeway for what you actually do choose um so that's wonderful and that counts as a rationale it's like we need to distinguish ourselves from the sea of green competitors or whatever you call other non-profits um so yeah it's like as long as you can have some solid reason you still you still have leeway in what you can do eric this conversation has been uh going amazing but we're going to take a break for a second and uh jason's going to tell us a little bit about oscon hey everyone so this is the uh last opportunity uh you know we do the show monthly and and the conference is going to be later on this month so definitely check it out um you can
在某种意义上，是的，有些东西你不应该把它做成那样，也许。但它给了你更多的余地来选择你真正想要的东西。所以这太棒了，这算是一个理由。就像我们需要将自己与绿色的竞争对手海洋区分开来，或者无论你称呼其他非营利组织为什么。所以是的，只要你能有一个充分的理由，你在做什么方面仍然有余地。Eric，这次谈话进行得非常棒，但我们要休息一下，Jason 要告诉我们一些关于 OSCon 的事情。嘿，大家好，所以这是最后的机会，你知道我们每月做一次节目，会议将在本月晚些时候举行，所以一定要去看看。你可以
still use the oscon.com slash PT. That's for programming throwdown. And you can get a pretty sweet discount. If you don't want to use that link, you can also use the discount code. So when you go to checkout, you do PT25 and get 25% off. I tried PT99.9. It doesn't work. PT25, that's the code you want to use. You get 25% off.
仍然使用 oscon.com/PT。那是 Programming Throwdown 的缩写。你可以得到一个相当不错的折扣。如果你不想使用那个链接，你也可以使用折扣码。所以当你去结账时，你输入 PT25，就可以获得 25% 的折扣。我试过 PT99.9。它不起作用。PT25，那是你想使用的代码。你可以获得 25% 的折扣。
It applies to all the different passes. So bronze, silver, and gold passes. On any of those, you can get 25% off. There's a bunch of open source folks that are going to be there. There's also just even more broadly a lot of opportunities to understand what's shaping software development. So they're going to be talking about AI. They're going to be talking about blockchain, pretty much cloud computing. Anything that you would read about if you're trying to read contemporary news on CS or software engineering is going to be talked about at length from industry experts. So people from Google, people from AWS. So yeah, give it a shot. The passes start at $750 when you register with that code.
它适用于所有不同的通行证。所以铜牌、银牌和金牌通行证。在任何这些通行证上，你都可以获得 25% 的折扣。那里会有很多开源人士。而且更广泛地说，还有很多机会去了解是什么在塑造软件开发。所以他们会谈论人工智能。他们会谈论区块链，几乎是云计算。任何如果你试图阅读当代计算机科学或软件工程新闻时会读到的东西，行业专家都会详细讨论。所以来自谷歌的人，来自 AWS 的人。所以是的，试一试。当你使用该代码注册时，通行证起价为 750 美元。
So try it out and let us know how it goes. If any of you go to the OSCon, shoot us an email. Let us know what you thought about it. Check it out. All right, Eric. So we talked a little bit about design and about colors. And all this is actually extremely fascinating. But once someone gets past sort of thinking through what they want a website to look at,
所以试一试，让我们知道结果如何。如果你们中有人去 OSCon，给我们发封邮件。让我们知道你的想法。去看看吧。好的，Eric。所以我们谈论了一些关于设计和颜色的事情。所有这些实际上都非常迷人。但一旦有人过了思考他们想要网站看起来像什么这一关，
there's the kind of, I want to spend a few minutes talking about, I don't know what you call it, like brass tacks, the fundamental aspects, like what equipment do you use to do your designs? We were talking about, you know, maybe don't choose a framework at first later, but most of the people listening to this
还有一种……我想花几分钟谈谈，我不知道你怎么称呼它，比如“基本事实”，基本方面，比如你用什么设备来做你的设计？我们谈到了，你知道，也许一开始不要选择框架，但大多数听这个节目的人
are probably coming from a programming background and they're itching to know, like what web framework should I use? Or if I'm building an app, like what language am I going to use? Or how am I going to make the design look? Do you have any sort of thoughts or comments about directing people on on first steps down down that avenue? Sure. Yeah. So it's a little bit tough, because it depends on like, how deep you want to get in the design rabbit hole um i think maybe the elephant in the room is what about bootstrap and i would just say the answer to this is going
可能来自编程背景，他们渴望知道，比如我应该使用什么 Web 框架？或者如果我正在构建一个应用程序，我将使用什么语言？或者我将如何让设计看起来很好？你对引导人们走上那条路有什么想法或评论吗？当然。是的。所以这有点困难，因为它取决于你想在设计兔子洞里走多深。嗯，我想房间里的大象可能是 Bootstrap 怎么样？我只想说这个答案会
to vary depending on how deep you want to go with design but uh bootstrap is great in that it really makes it really solves some problems that it would have just been nice if like native html just had done um and it and it gets things that look nice and consistent but if you use the default fonts and the default colors and the default icons you're going to have a site that looks like a bootstrap site and that that is kind of like wandering into the environmental ngo space with a green logo that has like a tree growing out of a hand or something. So you're definitely not setting yourself apart by doing that. And yet I recognize at the same time, it's like depending on what else you have going on, if you're coming from a backend perspective, to just be like, yeah, just learn CSS and roll it all yourself. It's like, that's a tall order,
根据你想在设计上走多深而有所不同。但 Bootstrap 很棒，因为它确实解决了一些问题，如果原生 HTML 已经解决了这些问题会很好。它让东西看起来既漂亮又一致。但如果你使用默认字体、默认颜色和默认图标，你的网站看起来就会像一个 Bootstrap 网站。这有点像带着一个绿色标志走进环保非营利组织的空间，标志上有一只手长出一棵树之类的。所以你绝对没有通过这样做让自己脱颖而出。然而，我同时也认识到，这取决于你还有什么其他事情要做，如果你来自后端视角，只是说，是的，学习 CSS 并自己完成所有事情。这就像，这是一个很高的要求，
especially if you're also trying to learn UX and UI design as well. So I'm not necessarily going to say that. That is what I do for most of my client projects at this point, is just do it all custom. Don't really start with a framework. But I think that's more just a personal preference. And I've been able to invest the time over the years to get good at the CSS and the visual design and knowing how they relate. So what you describe, and this is in my field, so it's probably a really poorly formed question, but I'm going to ask it anyways, which is, you know, describing drawings and wireframes and static things. But that healthcare website we were looking at earlier has some animation.
特别是如果你也试图学习 UX 和 UI 设计的话。所以我并不一定会那样说。这就是我现在为大多数客户项目所做的，就是全部定制。不要真的从框架开始。但我认为这更多只是个人偏好。多年来，我能够投入时间来精通 CSS 和视觉设计，并知道它们是如何关联的。所以你描述的，这是在我的领域，所以这可能是一个非常糟糕的问题，但我还是要问，就是，你知道，描述图纸、线框图和静态的东西。但我们之前看的那个医疗保健网站有一些动画。
I imagine sometimes people are going to be designing things with interactivity where there's going to be things moving around or changing or shifting or sort of flowing, not just a sort of static layout. How do you sort of reason about adding those elements or how to bring those in? Yeah, that's a great question. So this is something where, like, whatever your prototype is, whether it's a prototype in code, or a prototype in some some app that is made for animation, like Framer is a good example, then you almost need to get to that level before you can make the call of,
我想有时人们会设计带有交互性的东西，会有东西四处移动、改变、移动或流动，而不仅仅是一种静态布局。你如何推理添加这些元素或如何引入它们？是的，这是一个很好的问题。所以这是这样的，无论你的原型是什么，无论是代码中的原型，还是为动画制作的某种应用程序中的原型，比如 Framer 就是一个很好的例子，那么你几乎需要达到那个水平，才能做出决定：
is this what we want to ship or not? So for me, a lot of times that does just happen in CSS because it's not going to save me any time to write it in Framer first. I'm still going to have to get in there and tweak the easing curves and whatever. But this is something that i would say as even if you're like no i'm not going to do a site with a bunch of animation and crazy stuff going on
这是我们想要发布的吗？所以对我来说，很多时候这确实发生在 CSS 中，因为先在 Framer 中编写它并不能节省我的时间。我仍然必须进去调整缓动曲线等等。但这是我会说的事情，即使你像“不，我不会做一个带有大量动画和疯狂东西的网站”，
it's like well do you have hover states do you have hover states on your buttons because that's something where you can try and make that call in a program like sketch and say okay i think my hover state is going to be this variation it's going to be blue it's a blue button but then when i have a hover state it's going to be blue. It's a blue button. But then when I have a hover state, it's going to be a slightly darker, maybe a little bit more saturated version of that same blue. And you kind of tweak it and you put those colors in your code. And it's like you need to play around with that in your browser, in my opinion. You need to see that in your browser before you can actually say, yes, this is what I want or this is not what I want. It happens all the time where I'm like, OK, this looks good in Sketch, but then I get it in CSS and it's like,
就像，你有悬停状态吗？你的按钮有悬停状态吗？因为那是你可以尝试在 Sketch 这样的程序中做出决定的地方，说“好吧，我认为我的悬停状态将是这种变化，它将是蓝色的，它是一个蓝色按钮，但当我有一个悬停状态时，它将是蓝色的。”它是一个蓝色按钮。但当我有一个悬停状态时，它将是稍微深一点，也许饱和度更高一点的相同蓝色。你调整它，然后把这些颜色放进你的代码里。就像你需要在我看来在浏览器中摆弄它。你需要先在浏览器中看到它，然后才能真正说，是的，这是我想要的，或者这不是我想要的。这种情况一直发生，我心想，好吧，这在 Sketch 中看起来不错，但当我把它放进 CSS 中时，就像，
oh, this feels actually like really drastic, like hovering okay, this looks good in Sketch, but then I get it in CSS, and it's like, oh, this feels actually really drastic. Hover states, it should be subtle, but it should be noticeable. And it's like just getting that balance kind of right. It's like I don't need something to flash too dramatically or whatever. And yet I do want people to be able to tell when they're hovering on something. Almost everything clickable should have some sort of indication that you can click on it. So that's a problem even if you don't go deep into animation. So how transferable is the, you're sort of describing, you know, kind of like CSS,
哦，这感觉实际上非常剧烈，就像悬停……好吧，这在 Sketch 中看起来不错，但当我把它放进 CSS 中时，就像，哦，这感觉实际上非常剧烈。悬停状态，它应该是微妙的，但应该是显而易见的。就像把那种平衡弄对。就像我不需要什么东西闪烁得太剧烈之类的。然而，我确实希望人们在悬停在某物上时能够分辨出来。几乎所有可点击的东西都应该有某种指示，表明你可以点击它。所以即使你不深入研究动画，这也是一个问题。所以你描述的这种东西的可移植性如何，你知道，有点像 CSS，
which to me makes it sound like you're talking mostly about sort of web stuff. But if someone's saying, oh, I'm going to make an iOS or Android app, like how transferable do you feel? Like if someone came to you with a job to go design, and maybe that you have that in your portfolio, but come to you and say, Hey, I want to design for an iOS app. Do you feel confident in being able to transfer your skills? Or is it really a whole different world? Oh, yeah, absolutely. So with visual design, in particular, the foundations are exactly the same. There's some things that are a little more important on on web and bigger screens, tablet and desktop. Like white space is just going to be,
这对我来说听起来你主要是在谈论 Web 方面的东西。但如果有人说，哦，我要做一个 iOS 或 Android 应用程序，你觉得可移植性如何？如果有人带着一份工作来找你设计，也许你的作品集里有那个，但来找你说，嘿，我想为一个 iOS 应用程序设计。你觉得有信心能够转移你的技能吗？还是它真的是一个完全不同的世界？哦，是的，绝对。所以特别是视觉设计，基础是完全一样的。有些东西在 Web 和更大的屏幕、平板电脑和桌面上更重要。比如留白，它只是会……
it's going to be a little bit more. And then there's other things that are more important on mobile. Like you may need to get quite specific with exactly what font sizes and styling you use, just because you can't have a huge range of font size and styles. Like things need to be pretty compact
它会更多一点。然后还有其他东西在移动设备上更重要。比如你可能需要非常具体地使用你使用的字体大小和样式，只是因为你不能有巨大的字体大小和样式范围。就像东西需要非常紧凑，
or else they're going to run run over into multiple lines and be very very long on a mobile screen so because you have less of a range to work with you need to get more precise in that range um but yeah overall the two skills are like very transferable the thing that's more different is the ux the ux of a mobile app there's certain paradigms where, like in my opinion, the paradigms we've developed for how to navigate around mobile apps are brilliant. If you look, we use material design
否则它们会在移动屏幕上运行成多行并且非常非常长。所以因为你可用的范围更小，你需要在这个范围内变得更精确。但总的来说，这两项技能是非常可移植的。更不同的是 UX，移动应用程序的 UX。有一些范式，比如，在我看来，我们为如何导航移动应用程序开发的范式是天才的。如果你看，我们使用 Material Design
as a fantastic example of this. We use like shadows to kind of hint at different layers of things that are sliding over each other or merging into one thing or dropping off the side of the screen or like they come on from the side of the screen or like they come on from the side of the screen while the content you were looking at kind of shrinks
作为一个很好的例子。我们使用阴影来暗示滑过彼此的不同层，或者合并成一个东西，或者从屏幕边缘掉落，或者它们从屏幕侧面进来，或者它们从屏幕侧面进来，而你正在看的内容某种程度上缩小了
towards the background or something like there's just we use so much um motion and sense of location and navigation and it's actually really subtle but you can open up any any like well professionally designed app on your phone and and just pay attention to when i go from one screen to the next they're almost never like just on like totally the same level like it's gonna appear as if something is rised is like once one uh notch closer to you and is sliding over the screen that you were just looking at um whether it's from the side or from the bottom or whatever there's just so much motion in 3D. And that's just one thing.
向背景移动之类的。我们使用了太多的运动和位置感以及导航，而且它实际上非常微妙，但你可以在手机上打开任何设计精良的应用程序，只需注意当我从一个屏幕转到下一个屏幕时，它们几乎从来不是完全处于同一水平。它看起来好像有什么东西升起来了，就像离你近了一个档次，并且滑过了你刚才正在看的屏幕，无论是从侧面还是从底部，或者无论什么，这里有太多的运动和 3D。这只是一件事。
But the UX of mobile apps extends a lot beyond that. We've just really had to deal with these space constraints. And I think we've kind of risen to the challenge. Yeah, that makes sense. That's awesome. I noticed with my Chase app, it's like that. When you go to pay, there's this three-step process, and each step is sliding over. And it makes you feel like all the three steps are there at the same time.
但移动应用程序的 UX 远不止于此。我们确实不得不处理这些空间限制。而且我认为我们已经迎接了挑战。是的，这很有道理。这太棒了。我注意到我的 Chase 应用程序，它是那样的。当你去付款时，有一个三步过程，每一步都在滑动。它让你觉得所有三个步骤都在同一时间存在。
You're just only looking at one at a time. It makes you feel like there's this landscape that you're crossing. Yeah, it's fantastic. I don't know that I'm going to stake any examples on the Chase app, but what you're saying sounds like a perfectly smart decision to make as a designer. Yeah, you almost do want to give users a sense of place even when they're in this abstract digital experience. So we talked a little bit about replicating things that we like or existing stuff. And then occasionally I'll run across something on the web where, I don't want to say like a fad, but something new is catching on. So the one that I remember vividly recently is when you would scroll down a page,
你只是每次只看一个。它让你觉得有一片你正在穿越的风景。是的，这太棒了。我不知道我是否会在 Chase 应用程序上押注任何例子，但你所说的话听起来是一个设计师做出的非常明智的决定。是的，你几乎确实想给用户一种位置感，即使他们处于这种抽象的数字体验中。所以我们谈论了一些关于复制我们喜欢的东西或现有的东西。然后偶尔我会在网上遇到一些东西，我不想说像一种时尚，但一些新的东西正在流行。所以我最近清楚记得的一个是当你向下滚动页面时，
the page wouldn't scroll down, it would scroll over. I don't know what that's called, but it would scroll to the right. So if you scroll down the page, the page wouldn't move sort of up on your screen. It would slide to the right. And it would just keep sliding and sliding. Yeah, okay. But obviously, like some ideas probably seem crazy at first but then they they catch on like how do you for i guess especially beginners like what is the balance
页面不会向下滚动，它会向侧面滚动。我不知道那叫什么，但它会向右滚动。所以如果你向下滚动页面，页面不会在你的屏幕上向上移动。它会向右滑动。而且它会一直滑动，一直滑动。是的，好吧。但显然，有些想法起初看起来很疯狂，但后来它们流行起来了。对于初学者来说，什么是平衡
between doing what it seems sort of safe and sort of pushing the boundaries or breaking them oh my gosh this is a good question and and i i um i'm gonna give this answer of it depends which i hate because whenever i say it depends it means i don't really know. It means there's probably some divider line that I just haven't thought about enough to articulate yet. But because a lot of trends in design, I feel like actually make a ton of sense. So when things started going much flatter around 2013, 2014, like all of our shadows and gradients just kind of dropped off. And all of a sudden, there were a lot of trends around like just say like really clean, simple fonts. And then shadows came back a little bit. And there have been certain trends around shadows.
在做看起来安全的事情和推动界限或打破它们之间？哦，天哪，这是一个好问题，我……我要给出“视情况而定”这个答案，我很讨厌这样，因为每当我说是“视情况而定”时，就意味着我真的不知道。这意味着可能有一条分界线，我还没有思考到足以表达出来的程度。但因为设计中的许多趋势，我觉得实际上非常有意义。所以当事情在 2013 年、2014 年左右变得更加扁平化时，就像我们所有的阴影和渐变都消失了。突然之间，有很多关于只使用非常干净、简单的字体的趋势。然后阴影又回来了一点。关于阴影有一些特定的趋势。
There were these like diagonal shadows that were there for app icons for like a year or two. And they looked really cool. And they still kind of look cool. And there's no harm in using them, but it was definitely like a trend where it very suddenly appeared and was adopted by a lot of people all at once. And then I feel like maybe in the last couple years, we've gotten so used to seeing these clean, simple, flat sites with very plain
有这些像应用程序图标的对角阴影，存在了一两年。它们看起来真的很酷。而且它们看起来仍然很酷。使用它们没有坏处，但这绝对是一种趋势，它非常突然地出现，并被很多人同时采用。然后我觉得也许在过去几年里，我们已经习惯了看到这些干净、简单、扁平的网站，带有非常朴素的
sans serif fonts. And now you see many more interesting serif fonts, especially at big sizes where you can see all the details of those fonts. And that's kind of a trend, but it's also an awesome trend. And when people pick these high-quality serifs and show them at really big sizes, like that Foundation Medicine is a decent example of it. We talked about how cool that font looks. It's like, I didn't even know what that one was.
无衬线字体。现在你看到了更多有趣的衬线字体，特别是在大尺寸下，你可以看到这些字体的所有细节。这是一种趋势，但它也是一种很棒的趋势。当人们选择这些高质量的衬线字体并以非常大的尺寸展示它们时，比如 Foundation Medicine 就是一个不错的例子。我们谈到了那个字体看起来有多酷。就像，我甚至不知道那是什么。
So yeah, in some sense, that's trendy. But it's also a trend that's very, it makes sense given where we are at and what everything else looks like at the time. So I wouldn't necessarily say don't use, don't do trendy stuff. Like it can work. And if you like how it looks,
所以是的，在某种意义上，那是时髦的。但它也是一种趋势，考虑到我们所处的位置以及当时其他所有东西看起来的样子，这是有意义的。所以我并不一定会说不要使用，不要做时髦的东西。它确实有效。如果你喜欢它看起来的样子，
and you have a rationale for why it should be that way go for it like i'm not going to tell you not to yeah i mean i guess with web one of the things is nice is the ability to update it's not like a book where you ship it and then that stays locked in that state forever where you're going to feel in five years like groaning when you remember what it was it looked like yeah you you can ship a if it's trendy and it goes away in two years you can always update your website and and do the new thing yeah totally so you also one thing i want to talk about for a few minutes uh before we finish up here is you mentioned that you do freelancing and i know this is something that that comes up a lot not necessarily
并且你有理由说明为什么它应该是那样，那就去做吧。我不会告诉你不要这样做。是的，我的意思是，我想 Web 的好处之一是更新的能力。它不像书，你发布了它，然后它就永远锁定在那种状态，五年后当你记得它看起来像什么时，你会感到呻吟。是的，你可以发布一个……如果它是时髦的，并且在两年内消失了，你总是可以更新你的网站并做新的事情。是的，完全可以。所以，在你结束之前，我还想谈谈的一件事是，你提到你做自由职业，我知道这经常出现，不一定
in design but even just in programming like working for the man or working for yourself or you know this back and forth and freelancing do you want to talk a little bit about how your experience has been freelancing like how do you how do you get work yeah like do you do you feel scared about that like i mean what has that been like for you because i feel a lot of people will at some point in their career sort of have that as an option or a question yeah no that's that's a great question okay the way i frame getting work as a freelancer is like this the very first project that you have to try and find you have say you say you don't have any freelance experience at this point um it's going to be tough it's going to be tough because you're going to need to convince someone to pay you money to do
在设计领域，甚至仅仅是在编程领域，无论是为别人打工还是为自己工作，或者是在自由职业中来回切换，你想聊聊你的自由职业经历吗？比如你是如何获得工作的？你对此感到害怕吗？我的意思是，这对你来说是什么样的体验？因为我觉得很多人在职业生涯的某个阶段都会把这作为一个选项或问题。
something that you have not done in the exact capacity that you're suggesting. And that's okay. That's just kind of the way of things. And you can't change that. So you do your first project. But if you do a good job, the moment you've done that first project, you now have, even if you had to go to a bunch of meetups to find this person, or you posted on a bunch of job sites, or whatever you had to do to track down this project. The moment you've completed your first project and done a good job at it, you now have two potential avenues where your next project could come from. It could either be A, the same person who wants to hire you again because you did such a good job, or B, someone that this person tells, like they tell someone else, one of their other like little CEO startup friends or someone else in the industry hey you're looking for a designer hire this person
做一些你还没有以你所建议的那种确切能力做过的事情。这没关系，这就是事情发展的规律，你无法改变。所以你完成了第一个项目，但如果你做得好，一旦你完成了第一个项目，你现在就有了——即使你不得不参加一堆聚会来找到这个人，或者你在很多招聘网站上发布了信息，或者为了追踪到这个项目你不得不做的任何事情——一旦你完成了第一个项目并且做得很好，你现在就有两个潜在的渠道来获取下一个项目。要么是A，同一个想再次雇佣你的人，因为你做得太好了；要么是B，这个人告诉别人，比如他们告诉其他CEO创业朋友或行业内的其他人，嘿，如果你在找设计师，雇佣这个人吧。
like eric did such a good job so you should hire him too um and the more and so that makes finding the second project easier than finding the first one and like it just continues and if you were to kind of chart this amount of work it takes to find each project, each incremental project as it comes. It's like on the whole, that chart should decrease as it moves to the right. You should just see the amount of work go down and down and down. And eventually it hits zero, where you don't even have to find, you don't even have to spend extra hours finding a project. Like you'll still need to do an intake process to make sure you're a good match for that client and they're a good match for you. But at some point it's like they emailed you and maybe
比如埃里克做得很好，所以你也应该雇佣他。这使得寻找第二个项目比寻找第一个项目更容易，而且它会持续下去。如果你把寻找每个项目所花费的工作量绘制成图表，随着每个增量项目的到来，总的来说，那张图表应该随着向右移动而下降。你应该看到工作量越来越少。最终它会降到零，你甚至不需要寻找，甚至不需要花费额外的时间去寻找项目。你仍然需要进行一个准入流程，以确保你和客户之间是很好的匹配。但在某个时候，他们会给你发邮件，也许
you said, yeah, like let's talk a little bit now. And if this looks good, I can start in two weeks and you just smoothly transition right over to the next project. And then at some point that amount of incremental work to find the next client would theoretically it goes negative, which I just interpret to mean uh you actually have more people coming to you with projects than you can actually take on there's more demands for your time more people who want to hand you money to do what you love than you can possibly say yes to and that's fantastic because then you can really start to specialize and um and you're not necessarily worried about the about the future and And you don't necessarily have this feast and famine cycle that afflicts a lot of freelancers.
你说，好的，我们现在聊聊吧。如果看起来不错，我可以在两周后开始，然后你就可以顺利过渡到下一个项目。在某个时候，寻找下一个客户的增量工作量理论上会变成负数，我将其解释为，实际上来找你做项目的人比你能承担的还要多。对你时间的需求更多，想给你钱让你做你热爱的事情的人比你能答应的还要多，这太棒了，因为这样你就可以真正开始专业化，而且你不必担心未来，也不必经历困扰许多自由职业者的那种饥饱不均的周期。
But the thing is, it is the toughest at first. And if you just kind of keep your eye on trying to get through that beginning hump to get to a point where it is smoother sailing. Like, I'm not going to speak for everyone here, but it just feels like it gets better and better. So you I mean, inevitably, you have the someone doesn't pay or you did something and the communications was poor and the expectations are mismatched. Do you sort of establish up front how you plan to deal with that? Do you just sort of take it as it comes? Like, I feel like that's a sort of unknown or unknown, unknown, the thing that sort of scares people like, well, what's going to happen? Yeah, I've had very few problems with not getting paid. And I believe even for people who really hemmed and hawed and also, OK, another disclaimer,
但问题是，起步阶段是最艰难的。如果你只是专注于度过那个初期的困难，到达一个航行更平稳的阶段。我不会在这里代表所有人说话，但感觉确实是越来越好。所以，不可避免地，你会遇到有人不付款，或者你做了某事但沟通很差，期望不匹配的情况。你是否会预先设定好如何处理这些问题？还是随遇而安？我觉得这是一种未知，或者说未知的未知，这种事情会让人们感到害怕，比如，会发生什么？是的，我在没收到钱方面遇到的问题很少。我相信即使对于那些真的犹豫不决的人，还有，好的，另一个免责声明，
these haven't been for years. Like the the clients who who who are who either don't pay you or or who really put up a stink about paying you, those are the clients. They're kind of the lower quality clients that you have to settle for early on in your career. Like when you get farther along, you can, and you have, you know, when you have that curve of how much incremental work is it to find your next client and that starts to decrease it's like at some point you can just pass on someone who has those warning signs because one thing i've learned is clients typically if they it's no client has just one red flag and other than that looks like all green lights like it's either no red flags or like five of them so if you have a client that is like asking you at least as a designer they're like they seem like they're going to be really micromanaging. Like their feedback is not particularly good.
这些并不是多年来的情况。那些不付钱或者在付钱时大吵大闹的客户，他们是你在职业生涯早期不得不妥协的低质量客户。当你走得更远时，当你有了寻找下一个客户的增量工作量曲线，并且它开始下降时，在某个时候，你可以直接拒绝那些有危险信号的人。因为我学到的一件事是，客户通常——如果他们——没有客户只有一个危险信号，而其他方面看起来全是绿灯。要么没有危险信号，要么有五个。所以如果你有一个客户，至少作为设计师，他们看起来好像会非常微观管理。比如他们的反馈不是特别好。
Their communications are not great. It's like, that's also going to be the client who struggles to pay you on time. And the moment you can avoid them, you should. But in the beginning days, sometimes you just kind of have to risk it. And that was like a... There's an interesting philosophical point there because I've noticed the same thing
他们的沟通也不太好。那么，这也会是那个难以按时付钱给你的客户。一旦你能避开他们，你就应该避开。但在初期，有时你不得不冒险。这是一个……这里有一个有趣的哲学观点，因为我注意到了同样的事情，
in dealing with intra intra office situations that that invariably there are times where just it's just like a like a meteor strike or just something happens that just causes conflict. But but but ninety nine percent of the time when there's a conflict, one of those two people or probably even both of them or all of them have been in many other conflicts. So it's like that trend of you see something bad, there's probably a lot of other bad things. I mean, what's this saying? It's like if you see a cockroach, there's 50 other behind the wall or something like that. Oh, geez. Yeah, that's the same. It's the same point.
在处理办公室内部情况时，总是会有一些时候，就像流星撞击或者发生了什么事情导致了冲突。但是，百分之九十九的情况下，当发生冲突时，那两个人中的一个，或者可能两者都是，或者所有人，都经历过许多其他冲突。所以，这种趋势是，你看到了一些坏事，背后可能还有很多其他坏事。我的意思是，那句谚语怎么说？如果你看到一只蟑螂，墙后面还有50只，或者类似的话。哦，天哪。是的，这是同样的道理。这是同样的观点。
Yeah. Wow. That's a scary. I don't like that saying. I don't like it either. I don't think it's true. I mean, it's kind of, it's the same, it's the same point. Yeah. Wow. That was a, that's a scary, I don't like that. Yeah. I don't like it either. I don't think it's true. I mean, it's an old wives tale, but, but, but yeah, the idea is, you know, you're right
是的。哇。那很可怕。我不喜欢那句谚语。我也不喜欢。我不认为那是真的。我的意思是，这是一种老掉牙的说法，但是，但是，但是是的，这个想法是，你知道，你是对的，
that you can, while you're setting up the contract, it sounds like you, you, you, you, you, um, so I guess when you set up these contracts, you probably do it in person or on VC or something. So you can kind of see how the person is you know get that non-verbal communication no honestly no um so despite living in Seattle which is like a decent place and there's plenty of potential clients a very small proportion of my clients have been uh local it's it's more often than I'm going it's it's a remote job um so which is cool because it means you can freelance from basically anywhere uh but yeah i i why so that's a good question like why have i been able
你可以在设定合同时，听起来你，你，你，你，你，嗯，所以我猜当你设定这些合同时，你可能是在面对面或者通过视频会议之类的。所以你可以看出那个人是什么样的，你知道，获得那种非语言交流。不，老实说，没有。嗯，所以尽管住在西雅图，这是一个不错的地方，有很多潜在客户，但我很少有本地客户。更多时候是远程工作，这很酷，因为这意味着你基本上可以在任何地方做自由职业。但是，是的，我，我，为什么——这是一个好问题，为什么我能够
to do it without seeing the person's non-verbal communication um you know i'm not i don't know there might be an aspect of luck to it where it's like uh or or learning to identify those other red flags apart from oh oh, this person probably just won't pay me on time. Certainly, I mean, one warning sign for not getting paid on time is, is this project totally self-funded? Like if there's someone who is not discernibly rich, who is paying you thousands of dollars, that's going to hurt them a little bit. And they might have a lot of opinions that they want to make and a lot of things that they want exactly right before they pay you. And that's no fault to them.
在没有看到对方非语言交流的情况下做到这一点？你知道，我不知道，这可能有一点运气的成分，或者学会识别除了“哦，这个人可能不会按时付钱给我”之外的其他危险信号。当然，我的意思是，没有按时收到钱的一个警告信号是，这个项目是完全自筹资金的吗？如果有人并不是明显富有，却要付给你几千美元，这对他们来说会有点吃力。他们可能会有很多意见，在付钱之前有很多事情想要完全正确。这并不是他们的错。
But it's just something that you have to recognize as a freelancer. Okay, this might be this guy might be like really exacting, like overly exacting, perhaps he might actually make my life like pretty miserable and not worth the money that I'm getting for it. So it's just a potential thing to look out for. But especially if you already have a client who's raised money from VCs or something, and you're doing some work from them, or they're wealthy from another business, and they're trying to start this other thing, and they're getting you on board. It's like, those are good signs. Because one, I mean, one, it means they're not like lacking for the cash that they will pay you
但这只是你作为自由职业者必须认识到的事情。好的，这个人可能非常苛刻，过于苛刻，也许他实际上会让我的生活变得相当痛苦，而且不值得我为此得到的钱。所以这只是一个需要注意的潜在问题。但特别是如果你已经有一个从风险投资公司筹集了资金的客户，或者类似的情况，你正在为他们做一些工作，或者他们从另一项业务中很富有，他们正试图开始这项新业务，并让你加入。这就像，这些是好迹象。因为第一，我的意思是，第一，这意味着他们不缺付给你的现金，
with, which is great. They can keep up their end of the bargain. But it also means that they've passed some sort of real life filter for doing quality work. If you've raised VC money, like ostensibly, you're one of the few and one of the select and someone thought it was worth taking a very large bet on you. Likewise, if you had a prior business that was really successful, that's also a real life filter for people. Like not many people have successful businesses and are then going to start these projects and pay you thousands or tens of thousands of dollars just to see how the project goes. So like those are good signs. I found that the very best clients are extremely busy. And the funny thing about it is the very best clients I've had,
这很好。他们可以履行他们的承诺。但也意味着他们通过了某种现实生活中的高质量工作过滤器。如果你筹集了风险投资资金，表面上，你是少数被选中的人之一，有人认为在你身上下大赌注是值得的。同样，如果你之前有一项非常成功的业务，那也是人们的现实生活过滤器。没有多少人拥有成功的企业，然后会开始这些项目并支付数千或数万美元，只是为了看看项目进展如何。所以这些是好迹象。我发现最好的客户都非常忙。有趣的是，我遇到过的最好的客户，
they could have been designers and another life they easily could have done my job. I'm just there so that they can focus on the stuff that only they can do. And I just like make the design problems go away for them. So that's what I've learned. That makes sense. That's awesome. We've talked a little bit about people who who kind of work remote and obviously like what you're mentioning, like I don't know of a way to be more remote employee because I guess you're just by yourself. But it sounded like you didn't have anybody else. How do you I mean, how often do you find that you work from home versus work elsewhere? Not unless you're on a customer site, but just you just travel somewhere and you're you know, this is kind of always the dream you see sort of see pitched online. Like you could work from anywhere. You know, you could take a vacation to rome and be
他们在另一种生活中可能是设计师，他们很容易就能做我的工作。我只是在那里，这样他们就可以专注于只有他们能做的事情。我只是为他们解决设计问题。这就是我学到的。这很有道理。太棒了。我们聊了一些远程工作的人，显然像你提到的，我不知道有什么比这更远程的员工了，因为我想你只是一个人。但是听起来你没有其他人。你多久发现自己在家工作而不是在其他地方工作？除非你在客户现场，但你只是去某个地方旅行，你知道，这总是你在网上看到的梦想。就像你可以在任何地方工作。你知道，你可以去罗马度假，然后
working from your hotel room in rome um if that's something that appeals to you do you find that that's something that you do a lot or that you find is a little overrated um maybe both i think the thing is i now have two kids so long-term travel like so uh earlier this year we actually actually went to Spain for about a month and a half. And it was really nice. It was really relaxing. I got done a fraction of the work that I intended to. A lot of that was just now I'm traveling with a family. And so especially with young kids, it's like that's just tough.
在罗马的酒店房间里工作，如果这吸引你的话。你发现你经常这样做吗？还是你觉得这有点被高估了？也许两者都有。我觉得现在我有两个孩子，所以长期旅行，比如，今年早些时候我们实际上去了西班牙大约一个半月。这真的很棒。这真的很放松。我完成的工作量只是我预期的一小部分。很大程度上是因为我现在是带着家人旅行。所以特别是带着年幼的孩子，这真的很艰难。
Having a routine at home is a way better place for productivity. And that was something I kind of craved by the end of that trip is like ah like i really want to like actually get stuff done um yep but at the same time like um i was freelance when my wife and i got married and we i mean this was just incredible we we said wow we don't actually need to like have an end date on our honeymoon set ahead of time we can just going. And whenever the bank account runs low, we'll pause. I'll work and and then we'll keep going. And that was what we did. And so we took like a nine month lap around the world and it was just incredible. Wow. Yeah. So like the dream is real. And it's and if that's something where, you know, if anyone in your audience is thinking about doing that, yeah, it it's so possible um but it's
在家保持规律是提高生产力更好的方式。这是我在那次旅行结束时渴望的东西，就像“啊，我真的想真正完成一些事情”。是的，但与此同时，我在我和妻子结婚时是自由职业者，我们——我的意思是这太不可思议了——我们说，哇，我们不需要提前设定蜜月结束的日期，我们可以一直走下去。每当银行账户余额不足时，我们就停下来。我工作，然后我们继续。这就是我们所做的。所以我们进行了大约九个月的环球旅行，这真是太不可思议了。哇。是的。所以梦想是真实的。如果你的听众中有人在考虑这样做，是的，这完全有可能，但是
also it's not for everyone like it's it's something where i think i will do more when i have older kids like in terms of travel but um not for right now it's just a slightly different stage of life so i'm not really in the like doing long-term travel living the the tim ferris life or whatever so i mean that sounds pretty cool and you mentioned so you're sort of married and have kids but do you find that you look to other sources for sort of the water cooler kind of talk do you kind of like how do you fulfill that banter with other people that you might normally have around the office but that's sort of obviously missing in your setup oh yeah well so the water cooler banter is not really something i miss. I mean, I think it helps that I am totally an introvert. So by the time five o'clock rolls
它也不适合每个人。我认为当我孩子大一点的时候，我会做更多这样的旅行，但现在不行，这只是人生的不同阶段。所以我现在并没有真正过那种长期旅行、蒂姆·费里斯式的生活。所以，这听起来很酷。你提到你结婚了并且有孩子，但你是否发现你会从其他来源寻找那种“饮水机旁”的谈话？你如何满足那种你通常在办公室里会有的与他人的互动？这在你的设置中显然是缺失的。哦，是的，嗯，饮水机旁的闲聊并不是我真正怀念的东西。我的意思是，我认为这有帮助，因为我完全是一个内向的人。所以当五点钟到来时，
around, I've had like, maybe one meeting, like I'll have like two meetings a week or something. And so by the time five or 530 rolls around, I'm like, cool, I am now like amped up to like, go talk to friends and hang out and just have a good time all night or, you know, to a reasonable time in the night. Cause guy get up. But, um, so I think that helps. I've done like, for me,
我已经开过一次会了，比如我一周会有两次会议之类的。所以当五点或五点半到来时，我会想，太好了，我现在有动力去和朋友聊天，出去玩，整晚都玩得很开心，或者，你知道，在晚上合理的时间。因为我得起床。但是，所以我想这有帮助。对我来说，
it's just a personality thing. I think almost everyone else I've talked to who's been alone in their office, as long as I have, it's kind of like, this is a little miserable, man. And I'm like, I don't know.
这只是个性问题。我想我交谈过的几乎所有其他像我一样独自在办公室工作的人，都觉得这有点痛苦。而我却想，我不知道。
I like it. It works for me. Uh, so yeah, introversion helps. I don't know what else I can add there. I always just love hearing different people's take on it because like you pointed out, it works for you, but other people seem to be made miserable by it.
我喜欢它。它对我有效。所以是的，内向有帮助。我不知道我还能补充什么。我总是喜欢听不同人对此的看法，因为正如你指出的，它对你有效，但其他人似乎因此感到痛苦。
Yeah, yeah, it's tough. Well, and that's kind of the freelance thing in general. And what I say to people, it seems like everyone these days is just kind of, they wonder. They just wonder about freelance. They wonder if they could cut it and have just a life that's like 100% on their, mostly on their terms or whatever. And it's like, yeah, for some personality types, that's totally worth it. And I think I probably could have called this about myself. I had just never really stopped dreaming about starting my own thing or going freelance or whatever.
是的，是的，这很艰难。嗯，这就是自由职业的普遍情况。我对人们说的是，似乎现在每个人都只是，他们好奇。他们只是对自由职业感到好奇。他们想知道他们是否能胜任，并过上一种100%按照他们自己的意愿，或者类似的生活。而且，是的，对于某些性格类型来说，这绝对是值得的。我想我可能早就对自己做出了判断。我只是从未停止过梦想开始自己的事业或成为自由职业者之类的。
But for some people, oh my gosh, that's not the answer. You're going to be miserable. You're going to be miserable you're going to be alone you're going to have all this risk it's going to be really uh it's just going to weigh on you very heavily and the the rewards that come with working on an established team on an established project um with the same people day in and day out uh and that and that um and getting a reliable paycheck and not having to worry about that. It's like for some people, that's a much better deal.
但对于某些人来说，天哪，那不是答案。你会很痛苦。你会很痛苦，你会孤独，你会承担所有这些风险，这会非常……这会给你带来沉重的负担。而在一个成熟的团队中，在一个成熟的项目上，与同样的人日复一日地工作，以及那，以及那……并且获得可靠的薪水，不必担心这些。对于某些人来说，这是一个更好的交易。
So it's like, yeah, Freeland, it's just not for everyone. And I totally get that. This has been awesome. Before we sort of wrap it up here, you mentioned you have a blog that there's a course you have. Is there anything else that you want to pitch to people?
所以，是的，自由职业，它并不适合每个人。我完全理解这一点。这太棒了。在我们结束之前，你提到你有一个博客，你有一个课程。还有什么你想向大家推荐的吗？
How do people get in contact with you? All that fun stuff. Yeah, so probably the best way, if you liked the stuff that I said about design, the best way to check out more is to go to learnui.design. And that is, there's really, there's three things there. So I do have a course on user interface design. It's an online video course, 20 hours of video. It's like pretty comprehensive. It's everything I wished I had known when I first started doing visual design. So you can check that out, learnui.design. And then there's also the learnui.design blog, learnui.design slash blog.
人们如何与你联系？所有那些有趣的事情。是的，所以最好的方式，如果你喜欢我说的关于设计的内容，最好的方式是去learnui.design看看。那里真的有三件事。所以我确实有一门关于用户界面设计的课程。这是一个在线视频课程，20小时的视频。它非常全面。这是我刚开始做视觉设计时希望自己知道的一切。所以你可以去看看，learnui.design。然后还有learnui.design博客，learnui.design/blog。
That's all the like, I mean, it's a novel, at least, worth of free design content. It's all very analytical. It's just I've really tried to write in depth and write this sort of stuff that, again, I wished I had heard when I started doing this. So check that out as well. And there's also a newsletter where I send even more content, most of which, well, basically all of which is not on the blog. And that's at learnui.design slash newsletter.html. Hooray for using static pages. So yeah, that's probably the best place to learn more. And then you can also, if you have any questions, you can email me, eric at learnui.design or find me on Twitter.
那里面有至少一部小说价值的免费设计内容。它非常具有分析性。我真的试图深入写作，写出那种，再次强调，我刚开始做这个时希望听到过的内容。所以也去看看那个。还有一个时事通讯，我会发送更多内容，其中大部分，嗯，基本上所有内容都没有在博客上发布。网址是learnui.design/newsletter.html。为使用静态页面欢呼。所以是的，那可能是了解更多信息的最佳地点。然后你也可以，如果你有任何问题，你可以给我发电子邮件，eric@learnui.design，或者在Twitter上找到我。
It's Eric, E-R-I-K-D as in David Kennedy. Well, thank you so much for coming on the show. This has been awesome. Yeah, this is amazing. I feel like I'm going to go sign up to your newsletter right now
是Eric，E-R-I-K-D，像大卫·肯尼迪（David Kennedy）那样。非常感谢你来到节目。这太棒了。是的，这太神奇了。我觉得我现在就要去订阅你的时事通讯了，
because I'm curious to keep a pulse on this. This stuff's been fascinating. Awesome. Glad to hear it. Thank you for having me. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown Thank you for having me. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为我很好奇想保持对这个的关注。这些东西太迷人了。太棒了。很高兴听到这个。谢谢你邀请我。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown。谢谢你邀请我。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。